Ja, ich weiß, ich habe gestern gesagt, es geht heute um 9.30 Uhr los.
Aber was soll ich machen, wenn ich schon wach bin?
Ups.
Guck mal, Headset entknoten.
Excellent.
Vogue bin ich, ja.
Vogue.
Seid ihr auch schon Vogue?
Nicht so überwägt mit Vogue.
Hallo, ich möchte im Prozess Explorer starten.
Darf ich das machen auf dem zweiten Rechner?
Ist das möglich?
Yes.
Nein.
Darf ich nicht, ist verboten.
Warum darf ich den Prozess Explorer auf dem zweiten Rechner nicht starten?
Prozess Explorer, let's go, run.
Hat keinen Bock.
Der Desktop hängt wieder.
Mein Gott, der zweite Rechner ist so im Arsch.
Ist voll, ist komplett broken.
Chat, ich mache mal kurz Chat auf.
Giga Chat.
Ah ne, ich habe schon Chat auf.
Ja, moin Leute.
Mein zweiter Rechner ist gerade voll am abkacken.
Ich muss mal kurz warten, bis der sich beruhigt hat.
Ah, jetzt geht's, okay.
Jetzt geht's anscheinend.
Der Explorer hat aus irgendwelchen Gründen gerade ein CPU-Kern komplett blockiert.
Fragt mich, wie das funktioniert.
Was macht der denn?
Ah, jetzt hat sich's beruhigt.
Okay.
Kein Schimmer.
Das liegt bestimmt daran, dass immer noch Avira draufläuft.
So alt ist der Rechner schon, den ich hier zur Vorschau verwende.
Seht ihr jetzt nicht.
Aber da ist noch Avira.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
Ja, ich habe doch gerade gesagt, also ich habe es zwar gestern gesagt, 9.30 Uhr.
Aber was soll ich machen, wenn ich schon wach bin?
Avira ist richtig Monarch-S.
Aber sowas von.
So.
Jetzt, jetzt.
Jetzt scheint es zu funktionieren.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, was ich da für eine Windows-Version drauf habe.
Drei Jahre nicht geupdatet.
Sollte ich vielleicht mal machen.
Auf der anderen Seite der Rechner fliegt eh weg jetzt.
Demnächst.
Also, warum?
So.
Ja.
Ich habe auch noch Windows Defender.
Aber der alte Rechner ist halt so alt, da war noch Avira installiert.
Und ich habe nichts dran geändert.
Nee, war ich nicht.
Ich überlege gerade, was ist denn da drin?
Was ist in meinem Vorschau-Rechner gerade drin?
Was ist da drin?
Hm.
Ich weiß es.
Ich habe dazu ein Video gemacht.
Vor acht Jahren oder so.
Das ist der aktuelle Rechner.
Sekunde.
Da finde mal.
Das ist es nicht, oder?
Nee.
Moment, Moment.
Wo ist das Video zu meinem Rechner davor?
Hier.
Vor acht Jahren.
Den da.
Den habe ich jetzt gerade als Vorschau-Rechner.
Ja, genau.
Hier.
Einfach mal acht Jahre alt, das Ding.
Xeon-Vierkern.
Muss ich mal überlegen.
Acht Jahre alt und ist an sich eigentlich immer noch ganz okay, ne?
Rein von den Specs her ist das gar nicht so der Riesenunterschied zu aktuellen Rechnern.
Okay, es ist noch DDR3.
Mein Schneestelz wird immer noch empfohlen.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, warum.
Leute, ich habe, ernsthaft, ich habe legit, keine Ahnung.
Also, es ist, es ist, ich bekomme das auch öfters, dass ich auf YouTube.
Ähm, mit meinem zweiten Account.
Nee, das ist nicht, das ist Bergsteiger-Max, das ist was anderes.
Hier, den da.
Den bekomme ich immer noch empfohlen.
Ich auch auf meinem zweiten, also zweiten Browser, wo ich nicht eingeloggt bin, bekomme ich immer noch meinen Schneestelz empfohlen.
Der ist es halt, das Video ist halt auch komplett sinnlos.
Ich laufe durch meinen Garten.
So, ich meine, ich kann verstehen, warum das 1,3k Dislikes hat.
Das hat keine Sau interessiert.
Aber.
Aber warum hat YouTube, warum hat YouTube, ähm, ich weiß auch nicht, warum das so viel.
Warum hat YouTube dieses Video jemals empfohlen?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich verstehe es nicht.
Aber gut, wenn YouTube meint, die Leute möchten jetzt den Max-FPS-Schneestelz sehen, dann ist das halt so.
Na, was willst du machen?
YouTube hat sich damals gedacht, das muss auf die Startseite.
Zack, ich muss mal kurz was checken.
Nö, stimmt doch alles.
Klassiker wie Mozart.
Ja, genau.
So könnte man das aus YouTube-Algorithmus-Sicht sagen.
Video an sich ist ja nicht mal sonderlich gut.
Im Unterschied zu den Sachen von Mozart, die ja gut sind, die man heute kennt.
Mein Schnee-Video ist ja nicht mal gut.
Aber der YouTube-Algorithmus denkt, das ist ein Klassiker.
So ein reiner Vierkerner tut es doch auch noch ohne Probleme.
Zumindest für, jetzt nicht unbedingt für Spiele in der Kombi, auch mit der Grafikkarte, aber für so normales Zeug ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ich meine, man darf es nicht vergessen.
Der hat auch nur sechs Kerne hier.
Der, wo sieht man das jetzt?
Wo sieht man das jetzt?
Hier.
Konnte man den Taskmanager nicht so umstellen, dass man pro Kern das sieht?
Ging das nicht irgendwie?
Man konnte es doch irgendwie umstellen.
Rechtsklick.
Ah.
Ah, exquisite.
Na, das sind ja auch bloß, also gut, diese meine sind zwölf bei Hyper-Threading, aber ist ja auch nur sechs Kerne.
Das heißt, die Taskleiste-Anzeige ist auch hardcore typisch.
Die Bait eigentlich.
Das haben wir AMD zu verdanken, dass solche Kernanzahlen in Desktop-CPUs normal sind.
Ich rede jetzt nicht von meinen zwölf theoretischen, sondern von zwölf echten.
Was hatten, was hatten, was hatten nochmal ein Ryzen 9000 für, äh, ne, für, nicht 3.500, was hatten, was hatten der nochmal für Kerne?
Zwölf?
Sechzehn sogar, guck mal.
Und der andere, der hat dann zwölf, ne?
Ja.
Zwölf spricht der Hand.
Der hat quasi dann wahrscheinlich 24 logische, das ist schon hart.
Das hätte es ohne AMD nicht gegeben.
Mit Intel, also mit Intel würden wir immer noch mit vier bis sechs Kernen rumkrebsen und acht vielleicht im Super-High-End-Segment für 2000 Euro die CPU.
Also da können wir echt AMD dankbar sein, dass das, äh, so gekommen ist, wie es jetzt gekommen ist.
Not false, lul, ja.
Weißt du, aber das ist auch so, so wirklich so.
Und hier sieht man es mal so, 2021, man macht nichts auf seinem Rechner.
Na gut, nichts kann man nicht sagen.
Ich habe immerhin OBS und zwei Browser laufen.
Aber trotzdem, ich habe, ich habe vier Programme auf, aber es laufen 203 Prozesse.
Und davon sind wahrscheinlich die Hälfte irgendwelche Chrome-Tabs.
Woke.
Es ist unter Linux gar nicht mal so viel anders.
Wenn man da mal ein aktuelles Ubuntu startet und irgendwie ein Firefox auflöst.
Aufmachen, paar Tabs.
Und dann mal Hardtop aufmacht, kann man auch eine ganze Weile nach unten durchscrollen.
So.
Excellent, was gibt's denn?
Ja, ist echt so.
Ja, ich bin wach, ausnahmsweise.
Normalerweise bin ich am Anfang des Streams immer müde, aber heute geht's.
Woke mit Java.
Das ist eine gute Kombination, muss ich sagen.
Woke mit dem Java-Ding hier.
Habe ich Java-Time aktiviert bei mir im Chat?
Java-Time.
Tatsächlich, muss ich mal kurz testen.
Woke.
Das ist eine gute Kombination, die gefällt mir.
Wirst du Battlefield...
Ich, Tastatur.
Also, ich bin ja gar kein Flieger.
Also, ich habe weder in Battlefield 3 noch 4, noch werde ich jetzt in Battlefield 42 großartig Flugzeug oder Heli-Stells machen.
Und den Rest werde ich wahrscheinlich mit Tastatur fahren.
Ich sehe es nicht ein mit der Extra-Controller für Trans.
Man könnte mal machen.
Ich habe hier noch einen Original.
Original Xbox 360.
Was denkst du über die Wallhike-Spezialistin in 2.
Das ist die aus Südkorea, ne?
Die mit dieser hässlichen Brille auf.
Hier, die da.
BF2-Spezialist.
Mal gucken, ob wir...
Mal gucken, ob die uns das hier irgendwie ein Bild von zeigen.
Die haben doch nicht mal ihre Seite aktualisiert.
Jizo, Pike.
Genau, die...
Also, diese Brille, die sieht so dermaßen hässlich aus, Alter.
Wer sich das überlegt hat, ey, das ist so eine Brille draufzuhängen.
Das ist...
Das sieht wirklich richtig mies aus.
Und außerdem ist das...
Weiß nicht, das ist so low-poly alles.
Guck dir mal an, wie eckig die Backen sind und alles.
Obwohl das ja eigentlich so die high-resigsten Bilder sein sollen aller Zeiten, die sie hier reinhauen in so Promotion-Material.
Also, ich glaube, das ist gar nicht so wild.
Weil es doch sehr...
Situationsabhängig ist, ob das jetzt irgendwie was bringt, wo du dann beschossen wirst.
Also, ich glaube, das ist gar nicht so schlimm.
Das hat Riesenwellen gemacht.
Natürlich, wie so ziemlich alles.
Das irgendwie Dice macht.
Irgendwie Riesenwellen bei den Battlefield-Leuten schlägt.
Aber ich glaube mal, das ist gar nicht so schlimm.
Wir müssten uns mal angucken, wie es am Ende ist.
Also, wenn du das...
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe es mir jetzt im Detail noch nicht angeguckt, falls es da schon irgendwelche super...
Deepen Analysen und irgendwelche Data-Mining-Sachen aus der Beta oder was auch immer gibt.
Aber zumindest, wie das für mich im Announcement-Video ausgesehen hat.
Oder wo ich mal...
Ich hoffe mal, dass es nicht schlimmer wird.
Also, wenn du es jetzt alle, sagen wir mal, alle 5 Sekunden aktivieren kannst,
auch einfach so für Gegner, die nur rumlaufen,
dann ist es natürlich fragwürdig.
Also, wenn das quasi ein Motion-Sensor wird,
und nur halt mit Visual noch durch die Wand,
dann ist es wahrscheinlich zu krass.
Aber wenn du das nur ab und zu mal kurz hast für Leute, die dich irgendwo anschießen,
pfff, glaube, das ist nicht so wild.
Wenn du in Battlefield angeschossen wirst, bist du eh in der Regel dead von der Seite.
Oder, also du wirst selten aus einem sichtbaren Bereich irgendwie angeschossen,
so nah, dass du was machen kannst und der dich nicht direkt killt.
Also, ja, hier sieht man es ja.
Ich...
Oh, das ist tatsächlich nicht nur Leute, die dich anschießen.
Irgendwie habe ich es aus dem Trailer,
so verstanden, dass das irgendwie ein Gefahren-Display ist,
für Leute, die dich anschießen.
Wenn das natürlich permanent ist,
alle, oder zumindest, ähm, Großteil der Zeit,
dann ist es natürlich ätzend, sowas.
Aber ich bin immer noch unschlüssig, ob das wirklich so wild ist.
Ich finde es bescheuert überhaupt, dass es sowas gibt.
Ich meine, Wallhack-Scheiße brauchst du doch beim besten Willen nicht.
Da weißt du jetzt noch nicht mal, wenn dich einer um die Wand stellt,
ob der cheatet oder ob der nicht einfach nur diesen komischen, äh, legit Scanner anhat.
Das, so hab ich...
Das, so hab ich das nämlich verstanden.
Hier.
Automatically spot enemies who deal damage to you.
So hab ich das nämlich in der Vorschau verstanden.
Alter.
Ah, das hat sich ja ganz verdächtig nach Corona an, ey.
Ich muss mal kurz mein Headset entknoten, Zack.
So, ich glaube, jetzt ist...
Ja, jetzt glaube ich besser.
Excellent.
Also, so hab ich das nämlich verstanden in dem Trailer,
dass es...
dass es halt, äh, Gegner...
Gegner spottet, die dich anschießen.
Das ist natürlich...
Das wär nicht so wild.
So.
Und wenn das hier funktioniert, ist halt die Sache...
Wie oft, wie lang...
sinnvoll...
Tja...
Ich weiß nicht, warum es so Zeug braucht, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es...
Also, es gibt...
Es gibt bei solchen Sachen ja eigentlich nur zwei Varianten.
Zumindest ist mir das immer wieder aufgefallen bei solchen...
bei solchen, äh, Fähigkeiten.
Entweder...
Es ist so game-breaking-OP-as-fuck,
dass es quasi must-have ist und mehr oder weniger jeder spielt.
Oder es ist so komplett useless, dass es niemand verwendet.
Hm.
Ich glaube, so ein Zwischending gibt's da gar nicht.
Alter, was ist mit meinem Headset los?
Ich krieg Anfälle.
Hier.
Kannst du mal...
Kannst du mal einfach...
Alter.
Ist ja heute.
Los.
So.
Alter, mein Headset wird jetzt einfach mal ordentlich funktionieren.
Blitz.
So.
Ich rauche nicht.
Nee.
Mal gucken.
Ich glaube, wir müssen einfach mal abwarten, bis das Ganze rauskommt.
Dann, wie nervig das wird.
Ich gehe immer noch davon aus, wenn der Grappling-Hook von Webster so bleibt,
dass das mit das OP-ste ist, was es in dem Spiel geben wird.
Einfach, dass du auf Gebäude kannst, wo teilweise nicht mal Leitern drauf sind,
und du da, äh, zwei Minuten ungestört im Kreis rennen kannst und 20 Gegner killen,
ist schon krass.
Und...
Was soll...
Was soll denn beispielsweise...
Jetzt überlegen wir mal.
Schränkt mich das irgendwie ein, wenn ich hier so einen...
So einen...
So einen Wallhack-Overlay habe?
Klar, wenn ich hier in den Containern rumrelle, schon.
Wenn ich aber hier oben auf dem Dach bin, wo sonst keiner hinkommt,
und da runterballer,
ist es für mich gar nicht so wild, ob die...
Ob die da Wallhack hat oder nicht.
Kann eh nix dagegen machen.
Ja.
Teamwork is at all time low.
Das war aber auch in der Beta...
Den...
Den Bugs geschuldet.
Also, das Reviven hat ewig gedauert.
Du hast teilweise gar nicht richtig reviven können, weil du die Waffe der Gegner aufgehoben hast.
Und auch ansonsten war das alles ein bisschen detached.
Das stimmt schon.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das ein bisschen besser wird.
Außerdem muss man auch mal ehrlich sagen,
so richtig Teamwork gibt's ja eigentlich nur, wenn du mit deinen Bekannten spielst.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz hatte Battlefield schon immer so spontanes Teamwork.
Ne?
Also, ich glaube, jeder ist schon mal kurz geswitcht auf einen Engineer, wenn du irgendwie Panzer stellst.
Oder hat zumindest mal Leute wiederbelebt.
Oftmals nur rein aus Selbstzweck.
Also, ich hab...
Ich hab beispielsweise, wenn man Metro spielt oder sowas,
ich hab so viele Leute schon wiederbelebt,
einfach weil ich wusste, dass wir dann die Stellung nicht verlieren.
Was für mich auch wieder besser ist als umgedreht.
Also, manchmal...
Und das war halt das Coole mit dem Instant 100% Revive in Battlefield 3.
Du hast manchmal absichtlich, obwohl du eigentlich nur quasi egoistisches Bashen machen wolltest,
hast du trotzdem 10 Leute wiederbelebt.
Weil du wusstest,
ähm,
du bist gleich down, wenn du die Leute nicht wiederbelebt hast.
Also, sprich, du hast absichtlich, obwohl du so der egoistischste Spieler aller Zeiten bist in Battlefield 3,
hast du ab und zu mal auf 2, 3 Kills verzichtet, um 10 Leute wiederzubeleben.
Das war schon cool.
Also, das hat gut funktioniert.
Also, das wird mit der Wiederbelebungsgeschwindigkeit in Battlefield 2042 auf jeden Fall nicht der Fall sein.
Es gibt ja zwei Wiederbelebungs...
Ja, Specialists quasi, die so Spezialist...
Die so Spezialsachen haben.
Du hast ja einmal...
Den, den, äh, den Sunny, also aus Deutschland, der 100% wiederbeleben kann.
Und dann hast du den anderen Typ, weiß gar nicht, ob das der ist, könnte sein, dass das der ist,
der, äh, glaube ich, Quick Revive kann.
Quick Revive und ich glaube, konnte der dich auch in Loadout droppen?
Wie viel kostet das Battlefield?
Ähm, es gibt wieder zig verschiedene Editions, die eigentlich bis auf die mittlere,
also die kleine und die mittlere, gar keinen großartigen Sinn machen.
Ähm.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das irgendwo steht, was der Unterschied ist.
Hier, genau.
So, Standard Edition.
Also, das ist ja immer das Gleiche.
Also, das Einzige, wenn man, wenn man will, man kann sich die Gold Edition kaufen, weil,
nicht unbedingt wegen dem, wegen dem Pass, sondern weil man vielleicht Early Access eine Woche früher spielen will.
Aber dafür musst du halt gleich mal irgendwie 10 oder 20 Euro mehr ausgeben.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was der Unterschied ist.
Der Rest macht...
Also, das lohnt sich, finde ich, überhaupt gar nicht.
Digital Artbook und Soundtrack, das ist der useleste Shit überhaupt, mal ganz im Ernst.
Wenn wirklich irgendjemand sich den Kram angucken will, Digital Artbook und extra Digital Soundtrack,
dann geht der auf YouTube und guckt sich das an.
Und das Einzige ist vielleicht, weil du hier irgendwelche super Skins oder so kriegst,
wobei es ist wahrscheinlich auch im Sch...
Also, es lohnt sich nicht.
Also, das Einzige, was sich lohnt, ist die Standard Edition oder eventuell die Gold Edition,
wenn man eben Early Access in der Woche früher spielen will.
Aber ansonsten ist es eigentlich wurscht.
Was auch noch eine Möglichkeit ist, man kann sich...
Genau, schreibt nämlich gerade einer im Chat.
Man kann sich diesen EA Game Pass oder wie dieses Teil holen.
Wie heißt denn das?
EA heißt...
Nee, das heißt nicht EA Play.
EA Play heißt das, genau.
Und da kann man eine Mitgliedschaft abschließen und kann das dann spielen.
Ist gar nicht, was der Kram kostet.
Allerdings nur so lange spielen, wie man die Mitgliedschaft lastet.
Und dann kann man auch die Mitgliedschaft abschließen.
Für die anderen Seite, wenn man jetzt sagt, hey, man spielt das wahrscheinlich eh nicht so sonderlich lang,
dann kann man sich für 5 Dollar mal einen Monat lang angucken und sich das danach überlegen.
Was, du brauchst EA Play Pro?
Ernsthaft?
But why?
Das letzte Battlefield konnte ich aber noch mit normalem EA Play spielen.
She baited, würde ich sagen.
Das letzte Mal hat ganz normales EA Play ausgereicht.
Das war ich noch für Battlefield 5.
Da hatte ich nämlich auch mal kurz...
EA Play gekauft.
Weil ich mir nicht sicher war, ob ich das Game kaufen soll.
Oder war es Battlefield 1?
Sogar...
Keine Ahnung.
Naja, gut.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Also, man muss ja sagen,
auch wenn man hier mal beispielsweise auf das Subreddit guckt von Battlefield 2042.
Also man muss ja sagen, wenn die Beta 1 geschafft hat,
dann ist das...
die Spielerschaft so ein bisschen zu spät.
Also du hast immer noch ein paar, die finden es eigentlich ziemlich nice.
Und du hast ganz viele, die sagen jetzt durch die Beta,
also irgendwie habe ich mir das besser vorgestellt.
Ich muss sagen, am Anfang war ich voll begeistert.
Ihr wisst das ja, ne?
Ne, wobei, ich hatte ja da vier Phasen.
Ich hatte vier Phasen, was Battlefield 2042 angeht.
Ich habe gesagt, naja, das Game muss erstmal zeigen, was es kann.
Ich lasse mich da nicht mehr drauf halten.
Dann habe ich mir den ganzen Scheiß angeguckt.
Im Vorfeld habe ich gesehen, es wird ein modernes Battlefield,
was so ein bisschen Richtung Battlefield 3 geht.
Und da war ich dann schon so ein bisschen begeistert.
Obwohl ich mir vorher gesagt habe, hey, nicht so sehr hypen lassen,
weil am Ende kann es ja immer noch kacke sein.
So, da war ich voll begeistert.
Dann habe ich die Beta gespielt und war immer noch begeistert.
Am Anfang, ganz am Anfang von der Beta.
Also von diesem, wo wir bei diesem EA-Event mal früher uns das angucken durften.
Da war ich immer noch begeistert von.
Wobei ich mir da auch schon so im Hinterkopf gedacht habe,
aber ich wollte es selbst nicht wahrhaben.
So manche Sachen sind ein bisschen doof.
So, und als ich dann die Beta gespielt habe,
zwei, drei Tage mal auch wirklich viel, viel Spielzeit reingesteckt habe,
dann hatte ich so das Gefühl, okay, irgendwie haben sie ziemlich viel verkackt.
Im Nachhinein muss ich jetzt sagen, nachdem die Beta jetzt ja schon eine Weile rum ist,
sie haben viel verkackt.
Ich denke aber, vieles davon kann man beheben.
Ein paar Designentscheidungen sind immer fragwürdig.
Vor allem, dass jetzt rausgekommen ist, dass ja Battlefield 2042,
nämlich lange Zeit als Battle Royale wohl in der Entwicklung war
und man sich erst später entschieden hat, daraus ein klassisches Battlefield zu bauen.
Und das merkt man, vor allem an der Map merkt man das.
Und jetzt ist es bei mir so,
also gerade durch die Beta habe ich schon erkannt,
dass die da noch einiges machen müssen
und dass das Spiel auf jeden Fall in einem, sagen wir mal,
vielleicht nicht so weichem,
äh, Zustand rauskommt, wie man das gerne hätte.
Da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass da, dass da einiges im Argen ist, wenn das rauskommt.
Es gibt ja, es ist ja jetzt schon angekündigt, dass es wieder Gigabyte-weise Zero-Day-Patches geben wird.
Also das ist ja jetzt schon bekannt, was war ja auch klar.
Und jetzt ist es bei mir so, nachdem ich jetzt die Beta eine Weile nicht gespielt habe,
ich hätte jetzt schon wieder Bock, eine Runde.
Weil eins muss man sagen, insgesamt, auch wenn viele gesagt haben,
das Movement ist sehr Modern-War-verlastig, ist es auch, muss man echt sagen.
Also, das ist...
Das ist das, das ist das Call-of-Duty-igste Battlefield-Movement, finde ich, was ich je gesehen habe.
Wobei, Battlefield 5 hatte ja wohl relativ ähnliches Movement mit dem Sliden und sonst was,
da kann ich aber nichts zu sagen.
Das habe ich recht wenig gespielt.
Aber das Movement fühlt sich sehr stark nach Modern Warfare an, finde ich.
Von der Renngeschwindigkeit her, von der Slide, vom Sliden her.
Gut, sie haben auch so ein paar extra Sachen eingebaut, wie Bunnyhoppen und sowas,
was ja mittlerweile, äh, was ja ziemlich hier runtergeschraubt wird.
Naja, und jetzt würde ich es doch gerne wieder spielen.
Also, die haben das schon richtig gemacht, paar Sachen.
Also, die grundlegenden Battlefield-Sachen, das können die.
Das können die.
Also, das Movement hat sich gut angefühlt und ich finde auch, fand auch das Waffenhandling,
das hat sich echt nicht schlecht angefühlt.
Aber es fühlt sich, es fühlt sich schon sehr stark wie Warzone an.
Also, wie, wie das Modern Warfare Warzone.
Also, sowohl vom Movement her, auch alles drumherum.
Also, es ist wirklich ein...
Also, ich weiß nicht, ob man das so sagen kann, weil ich habe halt die letzten zwei nicht großartig gespielt.
Aber es ist das Call of Duty-igste Battlefield, was ich kenne.
Man hat ja Battlefield 3 damals schon vorgeworfen.
Sie würden sehr Call of Duty-mäßig machen.
Aber im Vergleich dazu ist BF2042 noch mehr, noch mehr Call of Duty.
Aber okay, ich meine, vielleicht gibt ihnen der Erfolg ja recht.
Ja, das mit den Bots, finde ich, das ist zum Beispiel mit den Bots,
ist so eine...
Ist so eine Spieleinheit, die verstehe ich auch.
Bots finde ich mega beschissen.
Das wird sich auch bei Release nicht ändern, dass ich das jetzt irgendwie gut finde oder so.
Ich fand das nice.
Also, nicht unbedingt das, dass du quasi...
Wobei das...
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, so schlimm war das mit dem Laser-Gunplay gar nicht.
Die Map ist halt riesig groß.
Was willst du, was willst du denn machen?
Willst du Waffen machen, die nach 50 Metern nix mehr treffen
und mit denen du quasi die Hälfte der Map keine Gegner beschießen kannst?
Oder wie?
Also...
Und auf ganz weite Entfernung kannst du jetzt auch nicht mit einem Assault-Rifle
irgendwie easy da die Leute wegbashen.
Also, es ist...
Gut, ich meine, das Recoil-Handling ist wieder einfach als Fuck.
Ja, du ziehst ein bisschen runter und gut ist, das stimmt schon.
Aber was mir tatsächlich Spaß gemacht hat bei der Beta, ist das Movement
und vor allem die Sache mit dem Grappling-Hook.
Weil das ist einfach mal was Neues, ja.
Ich meine, das ist natürlich für Leute, die jetzt einmal bei Apex gespielt haben oder sowas,
die sagen, ja, das ist so Apex-Abklatsch.
Hat auch garantiert da mit reingespielt.
100 Pro, die haben sich da garantiert mal beraten lassen von den Apex-Entwicklern.
100prozentig.
Aber letztendlich fand ich das doch mal ganz nice,
dass du Battlefield eben mit richtig krassem Movement spielen kannst.
Hatte seine Vor- und Nachteile, aber ich fand's cool.
Das ist jetzt auch der Punkt, ich würde sagen,
das Movement in Kombination mit dem Grappling-Hook ist das,
warum ich wieder Bock hab, das jetzt zu spielen.
Das macht echt Bock.
Was ist voraussetzung?
Für den Ramp, keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht.
Was nutzt du für deine Webseite und die Weiterleitung?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Was meinst du?
Welche der Webseiten?
Meinst du Keck, WSService?
Meinst du den Preis-Jam?
Was, äh, was meinst du?
Nee, das glaube ich nicht.
Also, die Idee, das für Last-Gen-Konsolen auch rauszubringen,
ist ganz klar stonks.
Was sonst?
Die wissen genau, dass PS4 und Xbox,
ich weiß, ich weiß nicht,
ich spreche den Namen nicht aus,
ich weiß nicht mehr, wie die Xbox-Dinger heißen aktuell.
Ich glaube, Xbox One war das letzte
und jetzt sind wir ja bei Xbox Series X.
Richtige, richtige Pains-Champ-Benahmung.
Aber das war eindeutig Stonks-Entscheidung,
das zu machen.
Und es ist ja auch nachvollziehbar.
Ach so, das ist gar nicht meine Seite.
Die hat einen Mod gemacht.
Ich glaube, das ist irgendein WordPress oder so.
Müssen wir mal den Sebaro fragen.
Wo ist der Sebaro eigentlich?
Das hat, glaube ich, der Sebaro gemacht.
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht, was das ist.
Wahrscheinlich WordPress oder so.
Kein Schimmer.
Das ist nicht von mir.
Ja, die Last-Gen-Konsolen haben halt
große Installationsbasis.
Da gibt es halt millionenfach.
Deswegen kann ich die Entscheidung schon verstehen.
Aber vielleicht kann sich noch einer dran erinnern.
Mit Battlefield 4 war das exakt das gleiche.
Battlefield 4 kam auch für Xbox 360
und PS3 noch raus.
Und ganz ehrlich, hat mal jemand von euch
Battlefield 4 auf der Xbox 360 gespielt?
Die Version, die ist so dermaßen beschissen gewesen.
Das kann man gar nicht...
Die Maps waren kleiner.
Die Maps hatten teilweise weniger Details.
Das sah einfach beschissen hoch.
Also, ganz, ganz schrecklich.
Also, Battlefield 4 auf der Xbox 360
war wirklich absoluter Hyper-Pains-Champ.
Und ich stelle mir das so ähnlich jetzt vor
mit Battlefield 2042 auf den alten Generationen.
Ja, aber dass das die Möglichkeiten stark sind,
ist limitiert.
Es ist alles eine Frage des Fokus, ja.
Das mit Zerstörung ist, denke ich,
nicht so das gute Beispiel.
Du hast, glaube ich, eher Probleme
mit eben der Mapgröße und der Spieleanzahl.
Und dann je nachdem halt,
auf was du dich eben verlässt,
was an Hardware da ist.
Wenn du dich nicht darauf verlassen kannst,
dass du beispielsweise eine schnelle SSD hast,
um irgendwas zu streamen,
wie in der alten Konsolengeneration,
ja, dann musst du halt im Zweifelsfall
weniger Details machen.
Aber du hast auch keinen Bock,
die Map in verschiedenen Versionen zu bauen
für alt und für neu und sowas in der Richtung.
Also, das ist alles eine Frage des Fokus.
Hätte man gesagt, hey,
man entwickelt das nur für PS4
und nur für Xbox One,
dann hättest du ein ähnliches Game machen können,
halt ein bisschen weniger detailliert und alles.
Aber so alles in allem ist natürlich schwierig.
Deswegen ist das Einzige Sinnvolle,
was sie machen können,
das zu downscalen auf die alte Konsolengeneration.
Die alte Konsolengeneration,
die alte Konsolengeneration ist eh nur da,
um mehr Sachen an den Mann zu bringen
und im Zweifelsfall dann sogar noch
die Konsolenverkäufer anzukurbeln,
weil die Leute sagen, oh, geiles Spiel,
ich will es jetzt auf der neuen Konsolengeneration spielen,
ich mache Upgrade,
inklusive Cross-Progression.
Also, du kannst ja auf der alten Konsolen
anfangen zu spielen und das mitnehmen auf die neuen.
Ja, die hellen, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
ich hab's, also, das ist wirklich eine Sache,
ich hab's, das tatsächlich war von Anfang an gesagt,
ich finde die Specialists vom Ansatz her nicht schlimm.
Und das hat mich in der Beta auch nicht davon abgebracht.
Ich finde die Idee mit den Specialists
erstens aus Stonks Sicht nachvollziehbar.
Damit können die einfach Kohle auf lange Sicht machen.
Und wenn das Spiel gut ist,
dann können wir, kann es für uns Spieler
ja eigentlich nichts Besseres geben,
wie dass das Spiel langfristig supportet wird.
Dass es nicht nach einem Jahr der Ofen aus ist
und es wie die heiße Kartoffel fallen gelassen wird,
wie Battlefield 5.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein guter Stonks Move von EA.
Das nächste ist natürlich, wie passen die in das Game?
Und ich hab ja gesagt, okay, eigentlich sind die,
also, hab ich, bevor ich die Beta gespielt habe,
hab ich ja gesagt, hey, eigentlich sind die Specialists
ja gar kein so großer Unterschied zu customizable Klassen
aus den alten Battlefields.
Sind sie auch erstmal nicht.
Ich meine, du hast immer noch
Medic Engineer, Assault, Recon.
Bloß, dass du jetzt halt Trades und Special Gadgets hast,
die du vorher customizest.
Auswählen konntest.
Aber mit dem Unterschied,
dass es halt nicht so ist, dass es
mal so schnell geswitcht werden kann,
wie beispielsweise vom Defi auf den Smoke Launcher oder sowas.
Nee, wie vom Medikit auf den Smoke Launcher.
Das war ja auch quasi, so könnte man sagen,
ein eigener Specialist von den Gadgets her.
Aber das geht ja nicht.
Und jetzt ist halt schon die Frage,
sind manche Sachen nicht zu stark und must have?
Das ist eigentlich eher das Problem, was ich sehe.
Also gar nicht so sehr in den Specialists selbst.
Aber hätte es zum Beispiel den Grappling Hook gegeben
als Gadget für den Assault in Battlefield 3 oder Battlefield 4,
dann wären auch 90% der Leute damit rumgelaufen.
Einfach weil Movement das Wichtigste in dem Spiel ist.
Also es ist jetzt egal, ob Specialist es ist.
Die Gadgets, also die exklusiven Gadgets machen es eigentlich aus.
Ja, und ein Nachteil der Helden, die sehe ich auch so
oder der Specialist sehe ich auch so,
dass es in der Beta halt so war, dass alles gleich aussieht.
Alle Seiten sahen gleich aus.
Das war schon dumm.
Rano, danke schön für den Sub.
Sorry, falls ich wieder irgendwas übersehe.
Karinors187, huge Prime Subscriptions hier.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber ich habe da meine Bedenken mit Bots.
Also ich finde Bots an sich ist übelsten Müll.
Wahrscheinlich in zwei, drei Tagen oder so.
Die stand ja lieferbar in eins bis drei Tagen.
Die Map war nicht gut.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was wir, also,
wo sich jetzt auch so schnell nichts mehr dran ändern wird.
Also, wenn angeblich, das haben sie gesagt bei uns,
Orbital quasi mit die beste und spaßigste Map ist.
Ich fand die Map nicht gut.
Also die Map war einfach nur groß, ohne irgendwie nennenswert was drauf.
Das ist, Orbital ist so eine typische Battle Royale Map.
Du hast so ein paar Highlights, so ein paar Hotspots
und der Rest drumherum ist Gelände zum rumflitzen.
Also das ist typische Battle Royale Map.
Für Battlefield hat mir da einiges gefehlt.
Ja, du hattest das riesen Landefeld oder Flugfeld
oder was das war bei Orbital, wo du im Prinzip nichts machen konntest.
Du könntest nicht drüber laufen, da bist du verreckt,
weil sie dich entweder vom Haus gegenüber, vom Hochhaus
oder von sonst wie oder Fahrzeuge gekillt haben.
Und es gab genau einen Tunnel, wo selbstborn war reinzugehen.
Also das einzige, was du machen konntest,
ist eigentlich auf dem Hausborn runterfliegen
oder oder ganz außen rum rennen, was du nicht machen kannst,
weil das irgendwie 15 Minuten dauert.
Also die Map hat mich auch nicht überzeugt.
Das ist so was, das wird sich jetzt auch nicht mehr großartig ändern.
Wusste gar nicht, dass es Pupke, Pupke alten Konsolen gab.
Die Battlefield 4 Beta, ja gut, der Battlefield 4 war halt übelst kaputt.
Ja, ist doch gut.
Wusste gar nicht, dass man das nicht durfte vorher.
Ich hätte gedacht, man darf nichts veröffentlichen, was den schadet,
ohne, ohne irgendwie irgendwie Zeit zu geben, das zu beheben.
Aber keine Ahnung, was die alles machen wollen.
Die Battlefield 3 Beta war tatsächlich ganz gut.
Sogar die Battlefield 3 Alpha war ganz gut mit dem LLV noch auf Metro.
Hast du mal Steam-Unternehmungs-Plots?
Ja, das funktioniert.
Allerdings gibt es halt nicht so viele Spiele, die funktionieren.
Es gibt mittlerweile immer mehr und auch relativ viele im Vergleich zu noch vor ein paar Jahren.
Aber im Vergleich zum normalen Steam-Katalog ist es natürlich immer noch wenig.
Ne, will ich nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, ich will kein Battlefield 3 Remastered.
Battlefield 3 ist eigentlich heute immer noch ziemlich gut.
Was ich haben will, ist ein neues, gutes Battlefield.
Und ich hoffe, das schaffen sie mit BF 2042.
Ja, ne, ich glaube es gibt keinen Rush.
Sie haben sich da so bedeckt gehalten, zu immer.
Ich glaube, es gibt keinen Rush.
Wäre natürlich doof.
Aber ich glaube, es gibt keinen Rush.
Rush war bestien.
Was gucken wir uns denn heute mal an?
Zeig mal her.
Woke, Wokje, Woke.
Was?
YouTube, jetzt hast du die Chance uns nochmal Dinger zu empfehlen.
New Battlefield.
Guck mal als hätten die mir zugehört.
Als hätten die mir zugehört.
Wo ist jetzt, und was ist da dran jetzt so?
Na gut, okay, dann müssen wir uns nicht angucken.
Ist, glaube ich, nichts so Nices dabei.
Long Range Sniping is back.
Ja, leider.
Ich sehe es schon kommen, dass wieder 50% der Leute am Arsch der Welt rumrennen und snipen.
Allerdings muss man sagen, in Battlefield 2042 ist das mit dem Snipen gar nicht so einfach.
Also es ist schwierig zu treffen.
Es ist schwierig zu treffen und es ist nicht wirklich reproduzierbar.
Also manchmal bist du drauf und schießt durch oder vorbei oder sonst was.
Die Gegner bewegen sich teilweise sehr abgehackt, was es schwierig ist zu prädikten, wo Gegner sind.
Nö.
Bam.
Huge.
So, also, was will uns YouTube heute empfehlen?
Gibt es da irgendwas?
But why?
Guck mal, geht doch nicht mal.
Firearms Experts react.
Ja, der kann ohne uns reacten.
China vs. USA in Taiwan droht jetzt der Krieg.
Eher nicht.
Die haben da beide keinen Bock drauf.
Wobei, den Chinesen traue ich alles zu.
Die Chinesen sind ja eh der Meinung, dass alles ihnen gehört hat drumherum.
Das sehe ich keine Chance.
Und was anderes öffentlich sagen darf sie auch nicht.
Truck camping in a blizzard.
Warum empfiehlt uns YouTube auf einmal irgendwelche Outdoor-Dinger?
Sieht mal, sehe ich so aus, als würde ich mich für irgendwie großartige Outdoor-Sachen interessieren.
Außerdem, ich glaube in dem Fall wäre so ein Tesla mit der Batterie tatsächlich...
...ganz gut, weil das alles, was ich bisher da drüber gesehen und gelesen habe, ist, dass das wohl eine ziemlich gute Klimaanlage hat dadurch, dass du quasi eben bei Minus draußen stehen kannst und es trotzdem schön war.
Die haben da ein Gartenstellvideos gesehen.
Fuck stimmt, ich habe mal ein Gartenstellvideos aufgemacht.
Jetzt denkt YouTube, ich will mir Outdoor-Sachen angucken.
Das wird es wahrscheinlich echt sein.
PlayStation 3 mit Zubehör vom Schrottplatz.
Tja, zeigt mal her.
Jo Leute und willkommen zu einem Video auf dem Timus Hardwares Kanal.
Ich war wieder beim Schrott und habe diesmal eine PlayStation 3 Slim inklusive zwei Controllern und eine PlayStation Motion Controller gefunden.
Ja, wie man sieht, ist die PlayStation 3 tatsächlich ziemlich, ziemlich dreckig.
Aber ich würde mal sagen, wir schauen uns die einzelnen Sachen einfach mal an und schauen, ob die noch funktionieren.
Ich gebe mir jetzt einfach mal vor.
Alter, ist das Move?
Das ist das Eis am Stiel hier, Alter.
Move Controller.
Der Dreck ist gefakt.
Meinst du, der hat den Dreck...
Der hat den Dreck einfach nur so drauf geschmissen, dass es irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, ob man, wenn man sowas findet, weil auch durchaus im Müll, da kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass man sowas im Müll findet.
Und gucken, was passiert.
Es passiert nichts.
Kann das Bild nicht scharf darstellen.
Okay, es funktioniert noch, alles klar.
Easy.
Ich habe gemerkt, die wird ziemlich heiß, wenn man darauf fasst, also ist das wahrscheinlich einer der Gründe.
Gut, easy.
So, jetzt wissen wir auch Bescheid, dass die PS4 noch, die PS3 noch funktioniert.
Wir modden ein DDR5-Modul und messen die Leistungsaufnahme.
Okay, das stelle ich mir nicht so spannend vor.
Dann lassen wir uns jetzt eine Runde von LevelCapture baden.
Das muss sein.
Einmal LevelCapture baden pro Stream.
Hast du eine Meinung zum Framework Laptop?
Jetzt brauche ich mal eine Frage.
Was ist das?
Gibt es ein neues JavaScript-Framework, was Laptop heißt?
Oder ist es ein Laptop vom Hersteller Framework?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich meine, es würde mich nicht wundern, wenn es Laptop-JS gäbe.
Oder würde es, jetzt ernsthaft, würde es irgendjemand wundern, wenn es Laptop-JS gäbe?
Gibt es anscheinend nicht.
Dann wird es doch mal Zeit, Leute.
Ich habe einen JavaScript-Framework-Name gefunden, der noch nicht belegt ist.
Laptop-JS, auf, auf.
Kommt morgen, gehe ich auch von aus.
Stonks.
Ansonsten weiß ich wirklich nicht, was du meinst.
Keine Ahnung.
Ach, ist ein Auto.
Ist ein modularer Laptop.
Das wusste ich nicht.
Ähm, kann ich, kenne ich nicht.
Kann ich auch nichts zu sagen.
Aber ich glaube mal, also es gab, es gab ja schon mehrere solcher Versuche von Smartphones bis, äh, ich glaube sogar auch schon Laptops.
Die meisten, die meisten End-User, außer wir hier vielleicht, ne, im Chat, wir sind ja immer die Ausnahme bei sowas, muss man sagen.
Ich glaube, die meisten brauchen sowas gar nicht oder wollen sowas gar nicht.
Die Stream-Qualität ist gerade auf 360p runter.
Tja.
Der Stream ist aber immer noch in 1080p on.
Okay, also, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Zack.
Level-Cap, Level-Cap-G-Bait, wollten, habe ich gesagt.
Level-Cap-G-Bait, also Level-Cap-G-Bait.
Ne, nicht der, nicht der Auer.
Level-Cap-G-Bait.
Jawohl, Level-Cap.
Ich wollte mir übrigens noch ein Highlight schneiden lassen aus meinen Streams, fällt mir gerade auf.
Lul.
Äh, ja.
Der eine, der eine Cutter hat gesagt, er kriegt es jetzt doch nicht.
So nach einer Woche oder so.
Jetzt haben sich noch zwei andere bei mir gemeldet.
Der eine muss mir noch seinen Discord-Namen schreiben, habe ich irgendwie auch nichts mehr von gehört.
Den anderen habe ich noch nicht geantwortet.
Ich sehe schon kommen, das wird nichts, Alter.
Das ist wieder der Wahnsinn.
Hat jemand Tipps, Moment, wir gucken nochmal kurz hin.
Hat jemand Tipps, welche Micro- oder RGB-LEDs für den Einstieg gut sind?
Ja, habe ich.
Also, das Beste ist, wenn du es ganz einfach haben willst,
möchte nur einen eigenen Loop den LEDs geben.
Dann steckst du es anscheinend.
Ach so, per Infrarot willst du die steuern.
Also, gut, da musst du dann gucken.
Also, die einfachste Variante für LEDs, wenn du dir selbst bauen willst, ist ein ESP866, zum Beispiel sowas hier.
Hier zu kaufen.
Als Controller.
Kostet auch nicht viel.
Kosten drei Stück 10 Euro bei Amazon und du kriegst bei AliExpress noch billiger.
Und als LED, keine Ahnung.
Wäre es...
Wäre es 2812 oder irgendwie sowas, LED-Strips.
Da brauchst du noch ein Netzteil und als Software, als Software flashst du das hier drauf.
Und dann ist easy as fuck.
Dann gehst du aufs Webinterface und kannst hier alles einstellen, was du willst.
Guck, hier siehst du es ja.
So sieht das...
What the fuck?
Monke?
Was ist das?
So sieht dann das Webinterface aus von dem Ding.
Also, du brauchst ein Netzteil.
In dem Fall 5 Volt.
Ein 5 Volt Netzteil für diese WS2812.
5 Volt.
Es sollte jetzt vielleicht nicht das billigste sein.
Also, so 5 Volt Netzteil, 1 Ampere ist definitiv zu wenig, wenn die Dinge hell sein sollen.
Also, wenn du hier bei Amazon WS...
Also, wenn du dir irgendwie sowas hier kaufst bei Amazon.
Wobei ich halt sagen würde, das ist die billigste Variante.
Ich finde es nicht die schönste Variante.
Die schönste Variante ist LED-SK.
Weil die haben...
Die haben noch ein...
Eine weiße LED dabei.
SK...
Ich habe aber vergessen, wie das heißt.
LED ist SK...
2...
Nee, SK6.
Ich glaube, das da.
Sind das die?
Ja, die sind ein bisschen teurer.
Die haben aber den Vorteil, du hast noch eine weiße LED dabei.
Du hast RGB und weiß.
Das ist dann schöner, wenn man eben richtiges Weiß haben will.
So.
Das in Kombination.
Du brauchst dann halt ein Netzteil.
Ich würde dir hier ein 5 Volt Netzteil und dann irgendwie was sagen wir mal 6 Ampere mindestens.
Wenn du halt ordentlich Helligkeit haben willst.
Ja, sowas hier zum Beispiel.
Oder halt auch noch mehr.
Ja, 5...
5 Volt 10 Ampere.
Viel mehr wirst du da wahrscheinlich auch nicht kriegen.
Da musst du halt gucken, dass du das dann aber auch nicht unbedingt per irgendwie Jumper-Kabel anschließt.
Sonst wird es ein bisschen warm.
Aber mit diesem Netzteil wird das schön hell.
Ja.
Und dann hast du WLED und kannst das hier einstellen.
Du kannst aber auch mal bei mir im Archiv gucken.
Wir haben schon öfters mal genau diese Kombi im Stream gemacht.
Und dann kannst du auch mal...
Ja.
Beispielsweise letzten Weihnachten haben wir LEDs für den Weihnachtsbaum damit gebaut.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich baue dieses Jahr eine neue Weihnachtsbaumbeleuchtung.
Und was ich mich gefragt habe.
Gibt es diesen Kram auch als Kette?
Nee, oder?
Weil das Ding eignet sich nicht für den Weihnachtsbaum.
Das ist Mist.
Das ist wunderbar, um es an der Wand lang zu machen.
Aber nicht für einen Baum.
Was nach BS-LED.
Das ist die Bullshit-LED.
Ja.
Ah, hier.
Ja, gut.
Das ist an sich schon mal ganz nice.
Aber ich will ja irgendwas zum Selbst ansteuern.
Welche sind denn das?
Da muss ich mal gucken.
Ja, Musik ist weg.
Das sind voll adressierbar.
Ja, ich will die aber selbst adressieren.
Also nicht mit dem Controller, sondern ich möchte selbst das machen.
Was sind das?
12 Volt?
5 Volt?
Weiß ich nicht.
Muss ich mal gucken.
So.
Wir gucken uns jetzt.
Wir lassen uns jetzt debaten von LevelCap.
Wie kommt's, by the way?
Zeitumstellung.
Hey, Leute.
LevelCap hier.
In dieser Woche im Gaming ist Battlefield 2042 weniger als zwei Wochen weg.
Warzone's neues Map bekommt einen Release-Tag.
Activision Blizzard hat riesige Veränderungen und viel mehr.
Ach, Kabelabstand und ESP dran.
Das geht.
Sind die 5 Volt oder 12 Volt?
Diese Woche begann es mit einem Tricklein von Battlefield 2042 Info.
Aufgrund von Dataminern Temporial.
Aber es war schnell.
Es war schnell.
Wundervoll.
Wunderbar.
Ja, das wissen wir schon.
Moment.
conversation.
Class Trails Ja, das war ja schon davon auszugehen.
Das konntest du ja sogar schon mit einem Bug schon in der Beta spielen.
Du konntest ja mit einem Bug, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das gesehen habt, es gab ja einen Bug in der Battlefield 2042 Beta, dass du als Sturmsoldat von Battlefield 3 spielen konntest, was ich eigentlich echt nice fand.
Ja, ein Portal. Ich fänd's viel cooler, wenn hier im echten Game drinne wär.
Das war meistens eine exagerierte Idealisierung von Battlefield 2042.
Wie Black Ops Trailer.
Von der ganzen Aufmachung her und sowas.
Was hat er uns da gerade für ein Twitter-Message gesagt, was?
Aus all Maps.
Und das ist gute Neuigkeiten, weil Battlefield 5 nicht so groß ist wie die letzten Titel.
Die neue Pazifik-Map.
Oh kehrs.
Ja gut, ganz viele kehrts, weil Warzone ja schon mittlerweile sehr ausgelutscht ist.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob sie das jetzt hinbekommen, das rüber zu retten, quasi so diesen ganzen...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Dieses ganze Warzone-Ökosystem, was entstanden ist aus Streams, YouTube-Channeln und halt auch...
auch immer noch vielen Spielern und Cheatern natürlich auch, in die neue Version.
Ja, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Also sprich, jetzt kommt Call of Duty auch mit einem Rootkit, wenn ich das richtig verstehe.
So wie alle aktuellen Anti-Cheats.
Was ist das für ein Typ da? Wen seh ich da?
Ist das der Ravensoft-Man?
Ich hab nichts, ich hab mir nichts zu Vanguard angeguckt bisher, gar nichts.
Also ich, ohne Scheiß, Vanguard lässt mich so extrem kalt.
Gar nichts. Ich expecte einfach nur, dass mir die Spiele Spaß machen.
Und das vielleicht länger als zwei Tage. Das wär schon nice.
Ah, Apex.
Was soll überhaupt das Setting von Vanguard sein? Ich glaube, Zweiter Weltkrieg, oder?
50%.
Watson's Ultimate has been totally overhauled.
Only one pylon can be active now, but it lasts forever and has a pool of shields instead of indefinitely recharging them.
It'll still block all incoming projectiles, but only if they're going to hit a surface within range and line of sight of the pylon.
Before it would just zap anything in a radius around the pylon.
Before these changes, Respawn have fixed some bugs, tweaked the loot and crafting values, and rebalanced pricing in arenas.
The Season 11 update launches on November 2nd and adds a new map called Stormpoint in Ash from Titanfall as a new legend.
All Cyberpunk updates in DLC have been pushed to 2022.
The delays are in line...
Das hat jetzt noch gefehlt.
...with reports that...
...the studio is making massive internal changes.
The goals of these changes is to stop crunch and fix poor communication between departments.
Moment, die crunchen immer noch?
Das ist bei denen jetzt einfach normal. Das ist jetzt schon default, oder was?
And while the good news is disappointing for players, it's a good sign that CD Projekt Red are committed to changing their workplace culture and practices for the better.
They had originally planned to launch Cyberpunk's next-gen upgrade and free DLC content this year,
alongside more patches.
The game's updated roadmap shows all of the content that we expected this year is launching in the first quarter of next year.
Ich habe mir das Spiel noch nicht gekauft, also wenn ich mir die Roadmap so ansehe, werde ich mir das Spiel vielleicht mal Ende 2022 angucken.
...the first quarter of next year.
The next-gen upgrade will likely be a complete edition that overhauls the entire game for both next-gen consoles and PC.
It's unclear what sort of fixes last-gen console players can expect.
Gar keine.
...that was likely. You'll see...
...some radical improvements as well.
Apparently Snoop Dogg has the scoop on some Grand Theft Auto news.
According to him, Dr. Dre is producing the music for a new Grand Theft Auto game.
Ja, die haben wir jetzt noch gefehlt.
In the past few months, tons of rumors have been flying around about the sixth entry in the franchise.
Ich hoffe, Snoop Dogg macht dann auch wieder Live-Gameplay, wie in Battlefield 1, wo er einen Joint geraucht hat und zwei Stunden im Graben nach links und rechts gelaufen ist.
Bestes Gameplay überhaupt.
...claim it'll be a modern revisit to Vice City.
A voice actor claimed he was working on the game, but it's unclear if he's working on a new game or a remaster.
And other leaks suggest that the game isn't launching until at least 2023.
But, according to Snoop, Dr. Dre is currently creating music connected to the GTA game that's coming out.
And to add a little bit of credibility to the speculation, Dre was featured in the GTA Online's Cayo Perico heist update last year.
Officially, Rockstar hasn't said anything about GTA Online.
...officially, Rockstar hasn't said anything about GTA Online.
Und wisst ihr, was los ist?
Activision-Blizzard-CEO Bobby Cox
erhielt die Veränderungen an der Firma
und nahm einen Salarie-Kart.
Oh, er nahm einen Salarie-Kart.
Also das heißt, anstatt 300 Millionen
kriegt er jetzt nur noch 290 Millionen, oder wie?
Oder wie ist das?
... der Board of Directors.
Die Veränderungen betreffen eine
Zerotoleranz-Harassment-Policy,
das Ende der forceten Arbitration
in Harassment- und Diskriminations-Klämpfen
and a plan to hire more women
and non-binary people.
Wisst ihr, warum?
Das ist so geil.
Das ist einfach nur...
Also man darf jetzt nicht denken,
dass er das jetzt macht,
weil er über Nacht die Erleuchtung bekommen hat,
dass das vielleicht gute Sachen wären.
Der hat festgestellt,
sie haben es jetzt versucht,
ein Jahr auszusetzen,
auszusitzen, fast ein Jahr,
und es hat nicht geklappt.
Die Leute reden immer noch drüber
und Blizzard wird...
Also es steht immer schlechter da.
Deswegen machen die das jetzt.
Die machen das doch nicht,
weil sie über Nacht irgendwie
die Erleuchtung erfahren haben.
Das ist alles Stonks, Leute.
Das ist alles Stonks.
Das ist eine Sache,
die muss man sich einfach immer mal merken.
Egal, was es ist.
Wenn ihr Werbung seht mit...
Wir haben jetzt unsere grüne Seite entdeckt
und sind jetzt voll umweltfreundlich.
Nein, die haben nicht über Nacht
ihre grüne Seite entdeckt.
Das ist einfach Stonks.
Wir haben über Nacht entdeckt,
Diversity und Gleichberechtigung
ist eine supergeile Sache.
Nein.
Nein, haben sie nicht entdeckt.
Die wissen einfach,
dass man damit Geld machen kann.
Stonks, denen geht es seltenst.
Ich will nicht sagen,
dass es keine Ausnahmen gibt.
Es gibt bestimmt die ein oder anderen Ausnahmen,
die da wirklich dahinter stehen.
Denen geht es seltenst
um die eigentliche Sache,
sondern einfach nur,
um Dinge zu machen,
die sich gerade gut verkaufen
oder die das Ansehen steigen
oder was auch immer.
Im Prinzip, unterm Strich,
es geht immer um Stonks
und sonst nix.
Geez, das Stokern ist
dennoch trotz der
lei Tatsachen.
Na Gott sei Dank. Wird ja auch mal Zeit. Nicht, dass ich mir eine kaufen wollte, aber Facebook-Login war ja nun wirklich absolut grausam.
... of an augmented reality workforce to life. Oculus will be rebranded as a meta-product starting next year.
Player-known's Battlegrounds-Company Krafton just purchased Subnautica-Developer Unknown Worlds.
The studio got its start with the asymmetrical competitive shooter Natural Selection, which was a Half-Life-Mod-turned-standalone-Title.
The game and its sequel proved to be popular, but never broke into the mainstream.
However, Subnautica was a smash hit on launch and propelled the small indie studio into superstar indie studio status.
The buyout by Krafton makes some sense, given both studios are heavily invested in immersive FPS experiences,
...
... and have a strong history with competitive multiplayer games.
Unknown Worlds will continue to operate as an independent studio, and it's unclear if they'll be working on PUBG-Titles or not.
Before we get to our final story this week, let us know how you're getting ready for Battlefield 2042.
Have you guys been able to score an next-gen console or get the upgrade parts you want for your PC?
I'd be very curious to know how the player base is doing as...
Noch einen Bot!
Das ist so demotivierend mit den Bots.
Let me know in the comments below.
Valorant is getting a new hero named Chamber.
The trailer revealing him has some serious Tron-Legacy vibes, and his abilities are pretty unique for Valorant.
His C-Ability is a pretty standard trap, but his Q, called Headhunter, gives him a heavy pistol.
His E-Ability is a teleport that lets him move between two placeable anchors.
And finally, his ultimate is a high-powered sniper rifle that can one-hit kill regardless of where you are.
If you land a hit on your enemies.
Killing an enemy with this rifle also creates a field around the body that slows enemies down.
Chamber will be added in an update on November 6th.
Hat Valorant eigentlich sowas wie eine Story?
Oder ist das so Overwatch-Style?
Wir machen im Nachhinein irgendwas zurecht.
...16th.
And that wraps it up for this week in gaming.
As always guys, thank you so much for watching and I'll see you next time.
This is Lovecap, signing off.
Excellent.
So, als halber ist es los.
Jetzt hat uns Levelcap mal wieder schön gebadet, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Ich glaube, die haben eine Backstory.
Ja, es ist wahrscheinlich Overwatch-Style.
Bei Overwatch wussten sie ja auch nicht am Anfang, was sie wirklich machen sollten.
Und haben da nach und nach immer welche Dinger eingebaut.
Was machen die eigentlich mit den McCree-Stories, wenn McCree jetzt nicht mehr McCree heißt?
Werden die jetzt retroaktiv noch umbenannt?
Oder wie? Wie läuft das jetzt?
Die werden ja den Kram nicht neu voicen und rendern lassen, was sie da schon gemacht haben.
Ah ja.
Invisible... Was für ein Ding...
Da haben wir wieder von Videos vorgeschlagen.
Hier.
100% Invisible Infrared Death Ray Laser.
What?
Der Typ ist eh durch.
Von dem haben wir schon ein paar Sachen geguckt, aber das ist eh vorbei.
Der macht immer so abgedrehtes Zeug.
Richtig?
Nun, ihr wisst ja, wie es auf diesem Kanal läuft.
Ich werde euch nicht nur über Infrared-Fotografie reden.
Das Einzige, mit dem ich Spaß haben kann, ist, wenn ich ein paar gigantische IR-Lasere baue.
Nun, falls ihr das nicht wisst...
Bau von gigantischen Lasern ist nicht wirklich günstig.
Aber glücklicherweise habe ich einen Sponsor, der sie unterstützt.
Also, ich hatte noch nie irgendwie das Verlangen danach, Laser zu bauen.
Aber hat ja jeder unterschiedliche Hobbys.
So kann er sein höchstes Potenzial erreichen.
Dieses Video wurde von Vikings War of Clans gesponsert.
Ah!
Erst es gibt ein Age of Empires Placement, bis mir dann aufgefallen ist, wie kacke das aussieht.
Warum?
Oh, ich, ich, das triggert mich immer so krass.
Warum sehen alle, aber auch wirklich alle Mobile Games vom Logo her gleich aus?
Die sehen alle so aus. Alle.
Immer.
Warum?
Und wenn ich mir das schon angucke, ist das wieder so ein typisches Mobile Game.
Wir bauen irgendwie eine Stadt oder so.
Ein Schrott.
Egal.
Hm.
Ich habe das Spiel gedownloadet und kann definitiv sehen, weshalb es so enttäuschend ist.
Es ist tatsächlich viel Spaß und...
Würde ich, würde ich auch erzählen, wenn die mir ordentlich Geld geben.
... wertvoll zu beurteilen.
Hilf mir, meinen Kanal zu unterstützen, indem ich Vikings gratis downloade.
Nur von meinen Linken in der Beschreibung unten.
Tolles Simplicissimus-Video von vorgestern.
Mit einem besonderen Bonus von 200 Euro.
Und einem Schutzschild oder so.
Wenn das ja nicht immer...
Wenn das ja nicht immer so übertreiben würde...
Mit den, äh...
Mit den Formulierungen drinnen.
Exposed.
Wie Konzerne ihre Gamer ausbauen.
Oh, das kann ich mir...
Ich kann mir das teilweise nicht mehr angucken.
Das ist...
Es ist ja nicht schlecht gemacht, die Videos.
Aber ich finde die immer so...
So von den Formulierungen her sind die immer so superlativenmäßig.
Also...
Aber wir können da trotzdem mal reingucken.
Wo sind wir denn jetzt hier stehen geblieben überhaupt?
Lol.
Sind wir hier.
Also jetzt müssen wir uns aber erstmal den 100% invisible IR Death Laser angucken.
Death Ray Laser.
Be sure to look me up and join my viking's clan under my name is Tyrell Conaway.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, kein viking's clan, nerv dich rum.
... ist никак fragil.
I should point out that the experiments that were done in this video...
Also, was will er denn eigentlich machen?
... were done for completely recreational purposes.
And in fact, if you were to try any of this stuff at home, you don't...
Was ist denn das.
Eine Säge?
Ist das das, wo die Amis mit ihren Lichtschalter in die Wand machen?
So, Kekona House?
... will certainly get killed, or at least paramed in their house.
So yeah.
Please don't try this at home.
Green laser pointers have a lot of fragile components inside.
What the fuck?
Was zur Hölle?
Was?
Okay.
Da kriegst du bestimmt Hautkrebs, wenn du dich damit anstrahlst.
Nicht nur ist es unbeleuchtet, es kann aber auch in einem kurzen Moment blind werden.
Und deshalb trage ich Laser-Goggeln, wenn ich damit arbeite.
Für die Zuschauer, die sich interessieren, mit Lasern zu experimentieren,
ein starker IR-Laser sollte nicht dein erstes Projekt sein.
Das ist wirklich cool an der IR-Kamera.
Und mit dem adjustable Lens Mount kann ich die Flasche auf einen kleinen Punkt fokussieren,
damit es die Dinge brennen kann.
Ich schiebe die Lichter sofort ein, wenn sie sich in den Fokuspunkt der Flasche befinden.
Nun kann ich auch durch dünne, dunkle Plastik mit Sicherheit schneiden.
Easy.
Okay, ich muss es machen.
Ich muss meine Hand auf die Flasche legen, um zu sehen, was passiert.
Nicht undisieren, nichts mit Krebs, na gut, dann verbrennst du halt die Haut.
... um zu sehen, was passiert, weil was möglicherweise falsch gehen könnte.
Oh, wow, ich fühle mich nicht so schlecht.
Nun, ich dachte, es wäre nicht schlecht, aber ich hoffe, es würde zumindest ein bisschen schmerzen.
Und sogar an dem Fokuspunkt fühle ich mich nicht so gut.
Guck mal, du kannst durch seine Hand durchgucken.
Ich glaube, meine Flasche ist einfach super transparent zu der kurzen Flasche IR-Wave-Länge.
Nun, bemerke, dass, wenn die Flasche durch meine Hand geht,
sie eigentlich alle meine Zähne leuchtet, damit sie deutlich aussehen.
Das ist so großartig.
Okay, jetzt bin ich müde.
Nun, es ist nicht so, dass diese Sache nicht mächtig ist.
Ich meine, es ist definitiv so.
Ich meine, komm schon, sie erreicht nicht mal die Klasse für eine Gefahrrate.
Ich fühle mich, dass ich etwas brauche, das mindestens 100-mal stärker ist.
Und nun, leider, ein riesiges, portables Ohr- oder Todesrad
ist nicht nur etwas, das ich online kaufen kann.
Also, ich glaube, das bedeutet, dass ich eine selbst bauen muss.
Nun, eine der Spaßpartien,
wenn es um so ein Laser-Design geht,
ist, dass ich komplett...
Nein, Schwachsinn.
Du hast keine geringere Wellenlänge,
du hast eine längere Wellenlänge.
Also, wenn du höhere Frequenzen machst,
hast du kürzere Wellenlängen. So rum.
Was soll denn da am Ende eigentlich rauskommen?
Aber mit ein bisschen Glück
konnte ich diesen verwendeten, aber funktionierenden 25-Watt-Unit zählen.
Für das Haus habe ich mit diesem Heatsink angefangen
und wollte es mit einem Hacksaug-Drill und Dremel machen.
Und wie bei den meisten Sachen in meinem Leben,
habe ich nichts geplant, bevor ich direkt reingehen wollte.
Ich habe angefangen, Dinge zu schneiden und Sachen in den Ort zu drehen,
bis es ziemlich akzeptabel aussah.
Ich habe am Ende eine Pipe für den Handel benutzt
und dann mit einem Schalter...
Also, ich weiß, dass ein unsichtbarer Death-Ray-Laser rauskommen soll,
aber aktuell habe ich noch nicht so genau kapiert,
was da eigentlich abgeht in dem Video.
Bevor ich den Laser-Array drückte,
habe ich einige arktische Silber hinzugefügt,
um den Laser zu erhöhen.
Ah, der hätte aber auch die Bauer-Wärmeleitpaste nehmen können.
Ich hätte die Indium-Foil-Paste benutzen sollen,
aber ich werde diesen nicht länger laufen,
also sollte das kein Problem sein.
Ich komme mit einem effizienten Fahrer,
der den Laser-Array zu füllen kann.
Oh, das wird meiner Katze bestimmt auch gefallen.
Aber dann habe ich ein Video von Marco Reps gesehen,
in dem er den exakten Fahrer baut, den ich benötige.
Der nächste Power-Supply ist eine konstante Ressource für den Laser-Array.
Ah, den Typ kenne ich.
Da gucke ich auch öfters die Videos von.
Ich habe ihn von jemandem,
der einige andere potenzielle Laser-Supplies hat,
und er will, dass ich zwei universelle,
konstante Ressourcen-Drohungen designen und zusammenbauen möchte.
Hier ist eine naive Anwendung.
Es ist lustig, denn meine naive Anwendung
wäre ein riesiges Pfeil von linearen Regulatoren gewesen.
Deshalb bin ich wirklich froh, dass ich sein Video gesehen habe.
Und ja, ich habe einen Drohnen gebaut,
basierend auf seinem Design,
und es funktioniert wunderbar.
Also ein großes Dankeschön an ihn.
Was kommt denn da jetzt raus am Ende?
Ich checke es immer noch nicht.
Ich werde zu Low-Brain führen.
Auf der Optikseite von Dingen,
bei denen ich etwas benötigen musste,
um den schnellen,
abfliegenden Beam von der Fibre zu verringern.
Ich habe einige Silica-Lens von Esco Optics benutzt.
Diese Sachen sind wertvoll,
um den High-Power-Laserbeam ohne Explosion zu beheben.
Ich habe die Lenses in einen
adaptierbaren Teleskop-Mount gestockt,
den ich von PVC-Pipes hergestellt habe.
Und hier ist das furchtbar beendete Produkt.
Ich habe hier einen Thermometer eingefügt,
damit ich die Laser-Diode-Stemme bemerken kann.
Ich habe auch...
Das könnte originalerweise aus Portal oder so was kommen,
dieses Ding.
Einer, der sich auflöst,
wenn der Laser am Arm ist,
und der andere,
wenn der Laser am Arm ist.
In irgendeinem Sinne genug mit diesem technischen Schmuck.
Lass uns das Ding ausprobieren.
Kannst du mich sehen?
Oh, warte.
Lass mich meinen riesigen Laser schalten.
Ich habe den Masch, den ich benutze,
mit Laser-Goggeln in einen Wärme-Helmet befestigt.
Ich will nur darauf achten,
dass es keine Chance gibt,
dass irgendein leeres Licht
in meine Goggeln kommt.
Die lustige Sache ist,
dass ich dieses Licht überhaupt nicht sehen kann.
Es ist völlig unbeleuchtet für mich.
Die einzige Grund, warum ich es ansehe,
ist von diesem Indikator-Licht,
auf dem ich mich befestigt habe.
Aber das gesagt,
ich bin sicher,
dass ich einen Licht-Goggel auf der IR-Kamera behält.
Das ist ziemlich verrückt für mich.
Auf meiner normalen Kamera
sieht der Beam wirklich schwach aus.
Aber offensichtlich ist das nicht der Fall.
Nun, was kann ich noch mit diesem riesigen Laser machen?
Wie soll ich einen 100.000-Volt-Spark-Gap starten?
Hier habe ich einen sehr...
Was sonst?
Hä?
Obvius!
Was soll man sonst damit machen?
Wenn die Elektroden zu nahe sind,
fällt der Spark einfach den Gap.
MonkaS,
übertreib's mal.
Ich fühle mich,
dass es zu schwach ist,
für einen totalen Breakdown.
Es ist eine kleine Menge Strom,
die seinen Weg durch den Gap findet.
Nun, wenn ich den Laser benutze,
um die Verbindungen zwischen den Elektroden zu leuchten,
kann der Spark wieder den Gap starten.
Das funktioniert,
weil die Flamme konduktive Ionen generiert,
die den präzisen Effekt der Elektroden erzeugen.
Ich bin sicher,
dass es auch einen Avalanche-Effekt gibt,
aus dem extremen Feld,
in dem die Gap startet,
und sie in neutralen Molekülen
weiterentwickelt wird,
um noch mehr Ionen zu erzeugen.
Die Plastiktübe hier
sind voller von Strontium Illuminate Glow Powder.
Wenn ich den Pile von Flaschpowder mit dem Laser leuchte,
energiert es den Illuminate,
sodass es gläubt.
Nun, wenn ich den IR-Laser an der Powder leuchte,
schlug der Glow weiter weiter.
In Wahrheit kann ich den Laser-Spot
durch die Gagel sehen.
So funktionieren die IR-Visualisier-Karten.
Jetzt, wenn es nicht für den extremen Blinding-Hazard
wäre, würde dieser auch als
die weltweit beste Nachtsicht-Flaschplatte funktionieren.
Dieser hat das Potenzial,
Dinge für Meilen zu leuchten.
Aber das wäre nicht sicher oder legal.
Also muss ich diesen einfach nur
für das Blöcken von Sachen zu Hause verwenden.
Nun, das war es von all den nützlichen Dingen,
die dieser Laser machen kann.
Jetzt schauen wir mal,
was er zerstören kann.
Der Typ hat ja mehrere solcher Videos,
also er scheint schon zu wissen,
was er macht.
Zumindest bis es mal in die Hose geht.
Also meinen Finger würde ich ja trotzdem nicht
reinhalten wollen.
Ja gut, man kann damit Dinge anzünden.
Wow, das habe ich mir schon gedacht im Vorfeld.
Natürlich ist es eine besonders ausgefallene Variante,
Dinge anzuzünden.
Aber gut, jetzt wissen wir,
wie man einen 100% invisible IR Death Ray
Laser macht.
Das war wichtig.
Das muss man unbedingt wissen.
Exzellent.
Man kann irgendein Taschentuch durchdingsen.
Ja, wie nennt man das?
Durchbrennen? Durchschneiden?
Was ist das richtige Wort dafür?
Gut, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Alles klar.
100% invisible IR Death Ray Laser.
So, und ihr meint jetzt wirklich,
oh, das sind 17 Minuten.
17 Minuten ist ganz schön lang.
Weiß ich nicht,
ich weiß nicht,
ob ich 17 Minuten Simplicissimus aushalte.
Durchlasern.
Durchlasern ist ein gutes Wort.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Durchlasern.
Rein da.
Na gut, komm.
Spielindustrie verdient immer mehr Geld.
Das klingt, ich kann das gar nicht beschreiben.
Das klingt immer so,
was ist das richtige Wort dafür?
So nicht vorwurfsvoll.
Ich weiß nicht, die Betonung von ihm,
die ist so speziell.
Als wäre das jetzt alles so furchtbar sensationell.
Furchtbar sensationelles.
Dramatisch, ja.
Dramatisch.
Videospielindustrie verdient immer mehr Geld.
Auch dank immer mehr Ingame-Verkäufen.
Battle Passes, Kosmetik.
Ja, gut, aber man muss natürlich auch sagen,
dass Gaming mittlerweile viel mehr Mainstream ist als früher.
Auch dank, was heißt dank?
Leider auch durch diese ganzen Kack-Mobile-Games.
Lootboxen, Items, Extraleben, Zeitüberspringer,
Diamanten, um Gold zu kaufen,
um damit Splitter zu kaufen.
Kurz Microtransactions.
Die sind leider häufig ziemlich ekelhaft und manipulativ.
Viel davon ist lange bekannt.
Teils wehren sich die Spieler,
aber leider wird es insgesamt nicht wirklich besser.
Warum? Warum sollte es auch besser werden?
Große Teile der Videospielbranche bewegen sich Schritt für Schritt
in eine ungesunde, gierige, rücksichtslose
und ausbeuterische Richtung.
Von einer Industrie, die viel zu wenig reguliert wird,
in der man sich für jeden noch so fiesen psychologischen Trick
nicht zu schade ist.
In der selbst die größten Entwickler ihre Seelen
an äußerst fragwürdige Geschäftsmodelle verkaufen.
Von Spielen, die kaum mehr sind als Dauerwerbeanzeigen,
bei denen echter Spielspaß und die Kunstform an ...
Alter, jetzt trägt er aber hier auf.
... allerletzter Stelle stehen.
Und die einigen ...
Gut, das ist ja so. Das stimmt schon.
... ganz bewusst und strategisch ausnehmen.
Das ...
Alter, Monka, es ...
We know that you put so much of your life
into the games we make.
Every moment you invest ...
Jetzt übertreibst du es mal nicht so.
... you feel like you are rewarded
and you are given value.
Make sure that your games ...
Der ist aber echt durch.
Den habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal geguckt,
irgendwelche Highlight-Videos.
Der ist echt durch.
Every moment you invest ...
... you feel like you are rewarded
and you are given value.
Make sure that your games are ...
... too skill-based.
... before you fight.
It's really saying something,
when a game almost makes EA look at it.
Das sind 57 bis 85 Cent pro Minute.
People have spent money on this game and wished on the ...
I'm sorry.
So. So, weiter.
Dieses Video ist in Kooperation mit GameTwo entstanden.
Trant liefert uns im Folgenden immer wieder seine Perspektive
als erfahrener Gaming-Journalist.
Außerdem findet ihr auf dem Kanal seines Teams
ein ergänzendes Video zu der Entstehungsgeschichte von Lootboxen.
Let's go.
Heute sind viele Games erst mal gratis für den Spieler.
Vermutlich um den Einstieg zu erleichtern
und um auch Menschen anzusprechen, die vielleicht keine ...
Das ist gar nicht das Problem.
Wisst ihr, was mich viel mehr abfuckt?
Nicht gratis Games, die die Leute ausnehmen.
Da ist es ja schon zu erwarten.
Was mich viel mehr abfuckt sind
Paid Games mit dem Scheiß drin.
... 50 bis 70 Euro ausgeben können oder wollen.
Entwickler müssen sich ihre Entwicklungskosten
dann anders wieder reinholen.
Zum Beispiel mit Mikrotransaktionen.
Eine Option sind zum Beispiel kaufbare kosmetische Inhalte
wie ein neues Outfit für den eigenen Charakter.
Die sind häufig ziemlich okay.
Also mir fällt zum Beispiel das Action-Rollenspiel Path of Exile ein.
Ja, die verdienen damit ihr Geld.
Das bietet seine kosmetischen Items halt sehr direkt an.
Du weißt genau, was du kaufst und was es kostet.
Also ich finde auch, PoE ist wirklich ein gutes Beispiel
und auch ein positives Beispiel, wie man das richtig machen kann.
Ich glaube, PoE war sogar ursprünglich mal ein Kickstarter-Game.
Bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher.
Ich habe das ja schon in der Beta zum ersten Mal gespielt damals.
Die machen das wirklich gut.
Du kannst das Game spielen.
Du willst, sagen wir mal,
das Game nicht wirklich ganz ohne Geld auszugeben spielen.
Zumindest einmalig ein paar Stash-Tabs
willst du dir auf jeden Fall kaufen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Leute gibt,
die PoE spielen mit den Standard 10
oder was es da gibt an beschränktem Truhenplatz.
Aber so ein paar Stash-Tabs willst du dir kaufen.
Aber preislich ist das durchaus im Rahmen.
Path of Exile übertreibt es bei irgendwelchen Limited-Skins
und sowas mit dem Geld.
Die kosten teilweise richtig viel Asche.
Aber die brauchst du nicht.
Die brauchst du nicht und ganz ehrlich,
die viele davon will ich auch gar nicht,
weil ich finde, dass die hässlich wie die Nacht sind.
Bei Path of Exile ist es bei mir
eines der wenigen Male so gewesen,
dass ich freiwillig gesagt habe,
ich kaufe mir irgendwelche sinnlosen Microtransactions,
weil ich das Spiel gut fand.
Also ich dachte mir, hey, das macht richtig Bock
und ich kaufe jetzt etwas,
was mir ingame gar nichts bringt,
z.B. irgendwelche Hideout-Maps oder sowas.
Einfach nur, weil ich das Spiel gut fand.
Warum berichtet Simplicissimus nicht über die Abzeuge der GEZ?
Du meinst unsere,
die Zwangsgebühren.
Na gut, der gehört ja irgendwie
zu diesem ganzen Kram dabei.
Außerdem ist es nicht Thema des Videos.
Brauche ich das oder brauche ich das nicht?
Du kannst es auch sehr gut ignorieren.
Alle Spieler haben in solchen Fällen weiterhin die gleichen Chancen.
Und Path of Exile macht es insofern ganz gut,
das muss ich jetzt auch mal sagen,
die haben zwar einen Shop,
der ist relativ prominent platziert,
aber es drückt es dir sonst nirgendwo ins Gesicht.
Du siehst, glaube ich, beim Startbildschirm mal was
und du kriegst relativ schnell einen Shop.
Aber du hast ja andere Sachen,
andere Games, die drücken dir es permanent
in your face,
diesen Scheiß.
Und das macht Path of Exile gar nicht.
Deswegen finde ich es auch fair gemacht.
Die Käufe sind einfach und klar
und das Gameplay wird nicht behindert.
Aber häufig machen Mikrotransaktionen
Spiele aktiv schlechter.
Ja, das ist so.
Spätestens, wenn man so komische Ausgeburten hat,
wie in diesem,
was war das, Battlefront 2?
Das letzte, Battlefront 2,
Remake oder New NG,
dass du 1000 Stunden
grinden musstest, um was zu bekommen
oder einfach nur in den Shop gehen kannst,
da sieht man eindeutig,
dass auch rein kosmetische Sachen
oder eben,
ja gut, das war noch nicht mal rein kosmetisch,
das waren ja Helden in Battlefront 2,
dass das auch Auswirkungen haben kann.
Also, das ist, was viele Leute sagen,
ja, du kannst es dir ja alles erspielen,
das ist ziemliche Mogelpackung.
Okay, wir haben diese Idee,
das Spiel, wie können wir...
Ja, warum haben die Battlefront 2 gefixt?
Nicht, weil sie so nette Menschen sind.
Die haben Battlefront 2 gefixt,
weil der Aufschrei der Spieler riesengroß war
und danach Disney gesagt hat,
wir möchten nicht mit dem Ausnehmen
von Kindern in Verbindung gebracht werden.
Also, ne,
nicht, weil sie so gute Menschen sind.
Klar.
Und viele Games ist halt,
der Aufschrei ist eigentlich immer nur am Anfang
relativ groß, wenn mal einer wieder
ein Spiel besucht.
Guck mal, wie weit wir gekommen sind
die letzten 10 Jahre von,
man regt sich auf, sobald es was gibt
in einem Page-Spiel zu,
man nimmt es eigentlich schon an,
dass auch in Bezahlspielen sowas drin ist.
Also, da hat sich die letzten 10 Jahre viel getan.
Sachen, worüber die Leute auf die Barrikaden
gegangen wären, sind heute vollkommen normal
und jucken keinen mehr.
... mit Geld verdienen,
sondern wie muss mein Spiel designt sein,
damit es möglichst viel Geld einbringt.
Richtig, ja.
...
Die Währung,
ja, das ist normal.
...
kostet drei Splitter.
Wie viel kostet der Haarschnitt in Euro?
80 Gems, ja, sind 50 Euro.
13 Splitter krieg ich dafür und sechs kostet die Frisur.
Five-Hat-Time.
Oh ... keine Ahnung, ich weiß es auch nicht.
So entkoppelt man Dinge im Ingame-Shop,
soweit es geht, von ihrem echten Preis,
um das Geldausgeben zu erleichtern.
Aber das ist nur der Anfang.
Make sure that your games aren't too skill-based.
Ja, das ist klar.
Na?
Du willst ja, dass die Leute durch Payment ihren Scheiß kriegen,
nicht durch Können.
I made that mistake myself.
A too skill-based game, you don't get people to pay you,
because there's no reason to.
Das ist ein Ausschnitt eines berühmt-berüchtigten Vortrages
eines Mobile-Spiele-Entwicklers darüber, wie man, na ja,
seine Spieler am besten austrickst und ausnimmt.
Regel Nummer eins, mit reinem Können
sollten Spieler im Game auf keinen Fall allzu weit kommen.
Hier betritt Pay to Win die Bühne.
Wer extra zahlt, z.B. für spezielle Items, hat einen Vorteil.
Das raubt aber vielen schnell den Spaß,
wenn man es als Entwickler übertreibt.
Pay to Progress ist da häufig effektiver.
Am Anfang geht alles ganz schnell im Spiel.
Man kommt gut voran, das Dorf ...
Ja, das ist typisches Mobile-Game.
Aber dann, damn.
Plötzlich geht alles superlangsam.
Elendige, sich immer wiederholende Aufgaben im Spiel
werden immer elendiger.
Man muss 30 Minuten warten, bis sich eine ...
Deswegen sehen ja auch alle Mobile-Games gleich aus.
Also, 90 Prozent der Mobile-Games sind ja solche Abklatsch-Aufbau-Dinger.
... wieder auffüllt, um weiterspielen zu können.
Oder man zahlt halt zwei Euro.
Und wer einmal damit anfängt, dem fällt jeder weitere Kauf einfacher.
Neben undurchschaubaren Wechselkursen
setzt man dann absurd hohe Preise für Gegenstände,
um zum richtigen Zeitpunkt ein Angebot
mit einem deutlich niedrigeren Preis zu ...
Ja, Chat, ich frag mich genauso wie ihr, wer diesen Scheiß spielt,
aber es gibt leider genug ... wir vielleicht nicht.
Deswegen, Mobile-Games.
Mir fällt's sogar schwierig, Spiele dazu zu sagen.
Ganz ehrlich, Mobile-Spiele sind zum größten Teil keine Spiele.
Mobile-Spiele sind eigentlich irgendein ...
Wie soll man das nennen?
Sandkasten?
Warteschlangen-Simulator?
Äh ...
Also, nicht Sandkasten, das hat der noch anscheinend von Sandbox.
Das ist der komplette Gegenteil davon.
Ich mein, das ist quasi so ...
Warteschlangen-Simulator ohne Gameplay ...
... sind die meisten Mobile-Games.
Die meisten Mobile-Games haben kein Gameplay.
Die haben im Prinzip 100 Menüs,
wo man irgendwas an Fake-Progress machen kann,
der am Ende aber keine Auswirkung hat,
weil es kein eigentliches Gameplay gibt.
So, das sind die meisten Mobile-Games.
Es gibt durchaus Mobile-Games, da ist das nicht so.
Aber der größte Teil der Mobile-Games ist so.
Diese ganzen Aufbau- ...
Fake-Aufbau-Spiele, wo man denkt, man baut irgendwas auf,
was aber eigentlich nie so wirklich auf irgendwas rausläuft,
die sind alle so.
Plötzlich sind 15 Euro für irgendeinen Scheiß in einem Handyspiel
ein guter Deal, weil Discount, das nennt man Anchoring.
Macht das Angebot noch zeitlich befristet und ...
Ja, das machen sie ja alle.
Und daneber, daneber da noch was, was eigentlich fast genauso gut ist,
aber weniger kostet.
Dann sagen die Leute, ja, okay, warum soll ich das kaufen für 30 Euro,
wenn ich doch das für 2 Euro kaufen kann?
Das ist auch ein beliebter Trick.
There are rare cards up here.
And you see the goblin going with his clock, tick-tock.
I'll take it away from you, I'll take it away from you.
This is a brilliant way to get more.
People to spend more.
Dann setzt man Bezahloptionen ganz gezielt,
wenn die Frustration am höchsten ist,
um die Irrationalität, den Hot-State des Spielers auszunutzen.
Ach, schon wieder Tore.
Willst du nicht für nur 138 Gold wiederbelebt werden?
Das verleitet natürlich dazu, das eigene Spiel so zu designen,
dass es diese Frustrationsmomente immer und immer und immer wieder gibt.
Und selbstverständlich nutzen viele Spiele
all diese Techniken gleichzeitig.
Raid Shadow Legends oder Hogwarts Mystery sind hier ...
Der darf natürlich nicht fehlen.
Paradebeispiele, siehe die starken Videos von Ultralativ zu dem Thema.
Stattdessen ist es weniger ein Spiel als ein animiertes Uhrwerk.
Ja, sag ich ja, ein Warteschlangen-Simulator.
... und schneller laufen lassen kann,
damit man sich am Wachstum der Zahlen
und im Fortschritt der eigenen Sammlung erfreuen kann.
Es ist das Abrufen und Monetarisieren ...
Es hat kein Gameplay.
Deswegen finde ich es auch immer dumm,
weil man das sagt, Mobile-Spiele.
Es gibt natürlich wirklich was mit Game, was man Spiele nennen kann.
Aber die meisten Mobile-Games sind keine Spiele in dem Sinn.
... und das ist furchtbar schade.
Die haben kein Gameplay.
Auch im neuen Pokémon Unite
gibt es undurchschaubar teure Scans.
Elendig langsamen Fortschritt,
um das eigene Lieblings-Pokémon freizuschalten.
Nintendo muss ja irgendwie Geld verdienen,
nachdem sie sonst gerade nicht so viel auf die Reihe kriegen.
... für ein vollständig ausgerüstetes Pokémon.
Oder 120 Euro.
Boah!
Siehe dazu dieses Video von Game Two.
Selbst die beliebtesten Franchises, die größten Marken ...
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was mich da besonders dran nervt?
Es ist ja die Entscheidung des Herstellers,
das zu machen.
Und es ist letztendlich die Entscheidung der Spieler,
das zu spielen.
Meinetwegen, okay.
Ich finde es zwar nicht gut, aber meinetwegen.
Was mich abfuckt, ist, wenn Leute dann sagen,
siehst du, ist doch gar nicht so schlimm.
Du kannst alles selbst freischalten, ohne auch nur einen Cent zu bezahlen.
Was natürlich offensichtlicher Schwachsinn ist.
Ich meine, gibst du 120 Euro aus, hast du fort oder musst du 480 Tage warten?
Kann mir doch keiner erzählen, dass das irgendwie angemessen ist,
vom Verhältnis her, ne?
Das Spiel ist absichtlich langsam gemacht, dass du das kaufst.
Also, das ist, was mich richtig nervt, ist, dass es so viele Leute gibt,
die diesen Scheiß verteidigen immer noch.
Und dann sagen, siehst du, ist doch gar nicht so schlimm.
... Pokémon oder 120 Euro.
Geil.
Siehe dazu dieses Video von Game Two.
Selbst die beliebtesten Franchises ...
Ah, Chat, Chat. Das gibt's doch sicherlich für Android, oder?
Ähm, ist das serverseitig?
Oder kann ich mir da mit irgendeinem manipulierten Game
einfach den Kram ercheaten?
Geht doch bestimmt, oder? Das ist doch bestimmt nicht gut gemacht.
Weil es ist wie bei Pokémon Go, GPS faken.
Dann spiel es doch einfach. Ja, das ist auch beliebt.
Die Spiele sind ja auch noch drauf ...
Weißt du, die ganzen Spiele tun ja auch alles dafür,
dass du trotzdem weiterspielen willst.
Wenn es so einfach wäre mit, dann spiel es doch einfach nicht.
Vor allem, wenn man z.B. großer Pokémon-Fan ist.
Die nutzen das ja geradeaus.
Was meint ihr, warum es letztens ein Herr-der-Ringe-Mobile-Game
gegeben hat?
Bestimmt nicht, weil die Welt danach geschrien hat und gesagt hat,
wir wollen ein neues Herr-der-Ringe-Mobile-Game.
Aber einfach, weil sich das mit dieser Lizenz gut verkauft.
Es kann halt einfach immer noch viele Fanboys.
... Euro. Geil.
Siehe dazu dieses Video von Game Two.
Die beliebtesten Franchises, die größten Marken
sind sich nicht zu schade für richtig schlechtes,
manipulatives Spieldesign.
Die haben ja auch viele Fans dahinter.
... und häufig noch irreführend vermarktet.
Tolle Cinematics, ernüchternde Realität.
Und am Ende, oh ja, das ist das Herr-der-Ringe-Mobile.
Genau.
Du denkst sonst was und dann ist es im Prinzip
ein weiterer Warteschlangen-Simulator.
Diese Techniken sind bei Handyspielen quasi Standard.
Sie werden oft einfach akzeptiert.
Aber allein das ist schon bitter.
Wenn man mal drüber nachdenkt.
Der Mobile-Gaming-Markt ist schon seit Jahren
der mit Abstand größte Teil der Industrie.
Es gibt immer mehr richtig große Menüspiele.
Weil jeder voll Noob-Mobile-Kram spielt.
Guck mal, meint ihr ernsthaft, die Hausfrau von um die Ecke ...
Sorry, wir sind 2018, es könnte auch der Hausmann sein.
Oder Haus-MWD, keine Ahnung, ist ja unbekommen egal dafür.
Dass der sonst nichts mit Spielen am Hut hat.
Der wird nicht das neue Battlefield kaufen.
Aber der kauft sich ...
Irgendwelche komischen Ingame-Sachen in Clash of Clans
oder in dem Herr-der-Ringe-MMO, Shadow Legends oder sonst was.
Der weiß noch nicht mal, dass Battlefield existiert, zum Beispiel.
Aber diesen Mobile-Scheiß, den kennen sie.
... Titel, die mobile-first entwickelt werden.
Die Grenze zwischen Geräten verschwimmt.
Handyspiele mögen Vorreiter sein.
Aber die Geschäftsmodelle erreichen längst auch Konsolen und PCs.
Ja.
Schauen wir uns als Nächstes die wohl perverseste Form
von Lootboxen an, über die wir noch gar nicht gesprochen haben.
Lootboxen sind in der Regel Packs oder Truhen.
Ich hab ja auch vor einer Weile gesagt,
wo Belgien angefangen hat, den Kram zu verbieten mit Lootboxen.
Ich hab sogar in einem Video dazu gesagt,
das wird ja nicht dazu führen, dass die Hersteller das nicht mehr machen.
Das wird einfach anders verpackt.
Und im schlimmsten Fall trägt es dazu bei,
dass es noch besser versteckt ist und quasi noch effektiver.
... finden sich zufällige Sachen mit unterschiedlichem Wert.
Wenn man diese Lootboxen für echtes Geld kaufen kann,
hat das ganz schön viele Ähnlichkeiten zu einem einarmenden Banditen.
Die psychologischen Mechanismen sind die gleichen.
Von knappen Nebenergebnissen bis hin zu Illusionen der Kontrolle
und Verlustjagd bei Problemspielern.
Zahlreiche Studien haben festgestellt,
je mehr Geld jemand für Lootboxen ausgibt,
desto problematischer ist das eigene Glücksspielverhalten.
Ja, und du hast auch viele Leute,
ich weiß nicht, da gibt's ein spezielles Wort für,
du hast auch viele Leute, sagen wir mal,
die geben 100 Euro für Lootboxen aus und haben, was weiß ich,
nur die Hälfte bekommen von dem, was sie haben wollen.
Oder keine Ahnung, die suchen fünf Items, haben eins davon bekommen.
Und jetzt sagen die Leute, hey, ich hab jetzt schon 100 Euro ausgegeben,
jetzt wäre es ja blöd, nicht noch mal 100 Euro auszugeben
für das andere Zeug.
Und wenn's dann immer noch so, jetzt hab ich ja schon 200 Euro ausgegeben,
jetzt hab ich das ja ganz umsonst reingesteckt.
Jetzt hab ich ja ganz umsonst
200 Euro reingesteckt, ähm, jetzt kann ich auch noch mal 100 Euro
und dann bekomm ich's drauf ausgeben, wisst ihr?
Also, das ist ... das ist ein bisschen ...
Ich weiß, der Vergleich hinkt jetzt ein bisschen,
muss ich jetzt aber sagen.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie, ähm, damals,
wo Leute sich eine PS3 gekauft haben zum Onlinespielen
und dann festgestellt haben, dass die Xbox, was online angeht,
obwohl sie gekostet hat, aber das bessere System ist.
Du hattest dann die Möglichkeit zu sagen,
fuck, vielleicht geb ich's zurück,
vielleicht war's keine gute Idee fürs Onlinespielen,
eine PS3 zu kaufen, ich will lieber eine Xbox.
Also, du hättest das einsehen können.
Oder du gehst einfach komplett steil unter jegliche YouTube-Videos,
die behaupten, die Xbox ist besser,
und verteidigst, dass die PlayStation 3 das Beste ist,
was seitgeschnitten brot.
Du willst es einfach nicht wahrhaben,
dass du 300 Euro in den Sand gesetzt hast,
die sich nicht eignen, oder 500, was du damals konntest,
die sich nicht eignen für das, was du machen willst.
Das ist aber bei vielen Sachen so,
wenn du zehn Jahre lang, was weiß ich,
stellt euch mal vor, keine Ahnung,
ihr seid zehn Jahre lang Mitglied in irgendeinem Verein,
oder was weiß ich, ihr spielt irgendwie zehn Jahre lang Lotto,
oder irgendwas, ihr gebt da Geld dafür aus,
dann ist die Versuchung zu sagen, ich mach weiter, einfach größer,
weil man im Hinterkopf sich denkt, guck mal,
wenn ich jetzt da einfach mit aufhöre,
dann stell ich ja in Frage, ob ich mich die letzten zehn Jahre
irgendwie richtig verhalten hab, oder sinnvoll verhalten hab.
Wenn ich einfach weitermach,
muss ich mir da keine Gedanken drüber machen.
Ich glaub, das spielt alles so in diese Richtung rein.
Grammix, danke schön für den Sub. Rico, auch danke für den Sub.
Sorry für all, die ich übersehen hab.
Es ist unklar, was hier was bedingt, beides wäre allerdings problematisch.
Lootboxen werden von vielen deshalb
als quasi unreguliertes Glücksspiel betrachtet.
Und dann richten sie sich häufig auch noch ganz klar
an Minderjährige und Kinder.
Sind eigentlich Slot- und Casino-Streams auf Twitch noch erlaubt?
... sind sie, wenn die Inhalte das Gameplay beeinflussen
und die Chance, etwas wirklich Brauchbares zu bekommen,
so richtig, richtig niedrig ist.
Wir haben selber schon vor Jahren darüber berichtet,
am Beispiel der Gelddruckmaschine des tollsten Spieleentwicklers der Welt,
FIFA von EA.
Das Spiel erscheint jedes Jahr mit minimalen Änderungen neu
für 50 bis 70 Euro.
Im Kernspielmodus Ultimate Team kann man sich jedes Jahr
wieder neu sein ultimatives Team zusammenstellen
und dann gegen andere antreten.
Leider bekommt man Spieler für sein Team vor allem aus Packs.
Was, es gibt derzeit eine Kontroverse um Montana Black?
Ich frag mich eher, wann es mal keine Kontroverse gibt.
Der Normalzustand ist doch eigentlich, dass da wieder irgendwas ist.
Aber bleibt einfach nicht aus ab einer gewissen Größe.
Wenn du da einen Furz lässt, schreien irgendwelche Leute rum.
... sind so richtig selten.
Und um viele Packs zu öffnen, muss man entweder
ganz, ganz viel spielen oder richtig viel Geld ausgeben.
Larry, what the ...
Don't do Packs, kids.
Einige Länder wie Belgien haben Lootboxen mittlerweile verboten
oder gehen in Teilen dagegen vor.
Seit neuestem ...
Da benennen sie's halt um.
Der Shitstorm ist so groß geworden, dass sich danach kaum ein Hersteller
mehr getraut hat, solche Mechaniken in ihr Premiumspiel einzubauen.
Daraus entstand dann einfach ein Rückgang dieser sehr offensiven
Lootboxen oder predatory business, sagt man eigentlich.
Ähm ...
Es traut sich heute kein großer Spielehersteller mehr.
Deswegen ist es ein bisschen seltener geworden.
Dafür verstecken sie jetzt irgendwelche komischen Dinger drin.
Aber in vielen Teilen der Industrie
sind Lootboxen weiter verbreitet denn je.
Dazu gehört auch drei Jahre später immer noch FIFA.
Klar.
Aber es gibt bei Ultimate Team doch neben den regulären ...
Dafür verstecken sie jetzt Dinger.
Du hast jetzt einen Season Pass, wo du die Level freikaufen kannst und so.
Das ...
Also ...
Es wird nie wieder weggehen, das ist sicher.
Es wird eher mehr und noch versteckter und, äh ...
Auch ...
Die lernen ja auch dazu, ne?
Also quasi mit jedem Fail ...
Also man freut sich ja immer, wenn irgendwie ein Hersteller's
mal richtig verkackt hat.
Sei es jetzt mit Battlefront 2 oder so, da denkt man ja, jawoll, bam.
Ihr seht ja mal, die können's nicht übertreiben.
In Wirklichkeit ist es so, aus jedem Fail, wo es nicht geklappt hat,
lernen die Hersteller ja.
Das ist blöd.
Die machen vielleicht keine guten Games mehr, aber das können sie.
Da sitzen wirklich big-plane Leute dran.
Aus jedem Fail wird ja da gelernt, um's dann besser zu machen.
Das heißt, irgendwann kriegen die das so gut hin,
dass es keiner mehr checkt und sich jeder das Geld aus den Taschen ziehen lässt.
Jetzt auch sogenannte Preview-Packs.
Dort kann man einmal alle 24 Stunden sehen,
was im Pack drin ist, bevor man es kauft.
So it doesn't look like a loot box, right?
Ähm, but there's concern that what people are going to be staking money on
isn't what's in their current open loot box, but in the one after it.
So you're essentially gambling on the next loot box down the line.
Das ist doch ...
War's nicht so bei den CS-Lootboxen, dass sie das irgendwie verboten haben?
Und du hast dann gesehen, was drin ist,
aber du musstest es dir dann irgendwie trotzdem ...
Die hatten doch richtig big-brain-Systeme,
seitdem die Lootboxen verboten haben.
Ich krieg das nicht mal zusammen.
Das neue System war quasi noch heftiger als das alte.
Du konntest reinschauen, aber keine neue kaufen,
wenn du nicht angenommen hast, genau.
Du konntest reinschauen, aber du musstest quasi ...
Ja, so was.
Aber aus Sicht von Zendel ist es wahrscheinlich nur ein Trick,
um Regulierung zu umgehen.
Ach!
Und auf den folgenden Inhalt, nicht den momentanen.
It's really easy to explain to a government
how a vanilla player pack corresponds with gambling.
These novel preview packs,
the mechanism appears like it might be exactly the same,
but the explanation is much more hard.
Den Modus Ultimate Team gibt es natürlich auch noch
in anderen großen Sportspielen von EA.
Gemeinsam sind die Ultimate-Team-Spielmodi verantwortlich ...
Die machen halt Geld ohne Ende.
... des gesamten Umsatzes von EA.
FIFA Ultimate Team allein macht nach Schätzungen ...
Richtig, man hat sich damals schon aufgeregt,
wenn es irgendeine OP-Waffe nur in einem DLC gab.
Heute ist das vollkommen Standard.
... circa 16 Prozent aus.
Sehr überspitzt, wenn man Lootboxen als Glücksspiel betrachtet,
wäre EAs Business zu fast ein Drittel ein Casino.
So nice.
Wir haben EA mit den Bedenken von Forschern wie Dr. Zendel konfrontiert.
Ja, natürlich, natürlich.
EA wird ...
Also, ich bin mal gespannt, ob sie's zugeben wenigstens.
EA betont, dass die Gesetzgebung in vielen Ländern
zu dem Schluss gekommen ist, dass Lootboxen kein Glücksspiel darstellen,
weil man nicht direkt Geld gewinnen kann.
Das ist auch die Sichtweise der Firma.
EA schreibt zusätzlich, dass es keinen wissenschaftlichen Konsens gebe,
ob Lootboxen wirklich gefährlich sind.
EA hat uns außerdem versichert, dass minderjährige FIFA-Spieler
im Median nur 37,20 Euro pro Jahr für Ultimate Team ausgeben.
Ach ja.
Ein anderes Beispiel wäre Genshin Impact.
Das ist ein Adventure-Rollenspiel mit Lootbox-Mechaniken,
das letztes Jahr ein riesiger Hit war.
Der YouTuber mtesht hat rund 1.700 Euro verzockt
beim Versuch, einen bestimmten Genshin-Impact-Kader zu ziehen.
Boah, das ist natürlich ordentlich.
Das hat ihn dazu verleitet, sich öffentlich bei allen Zuschauern
zu entschuldigen und komplett aufzuhören,
Geld in dem Spiel auszugeben.
So, richtig. Das ist gut, das ist gut.
Normalerweise wär's jetzt so,
das ist genau so ein Beispiel, was ich meine.
Also, der hat anscheinend wirklich bisschen, äh ...
Brain und, ähm ...
hat drüber nachgedacht.
Das ist jetzt der Punkt, wo du dich entscheiden musst zwischen ...
Ich konfrontiere mich selbst mit der Realität.
Ich hab 1.700 Euro quasi verbrannt.
Das ist ja quasi die Realität.
Ähm ...
Und jetzt ist halt die Frage an dieser Stelle.
Sagst du jetzt, fuck,
das ist so eine doofe Idee, ich pass jetzt in Zukunft besser auf.
Eventuell, eventuell mach ich ein Video drüber und sag,
Leute, lasst den Scheiß sein.
Oder aber, und das ist wahrscheinlich das,
wo sich 90 Prozent der Leute für entscheiden werden,
zu sagen, hey, ist doch alles gar nicht so schlimm.
Ähm, ich mach weiter damit.
Die meisten Leute wollen sich das nicht eingestehen.
Es ist für viele Leute, und ich kann das ja auch verstehen,
es ist unglaublich schwierig, sich einzugestehen,
wenn man ...
quasi es aus freien Stücken verschissen hat.
Also, es hat dich ja niemand dazu gezwungen.
Wenn es irgendwie Ausreden gibt, ähm, zu sagen,
dass jemand anderes dran schuld ist, dann macht man das ja immer.
Dann sagt man, ja, ich kann da nix dafür, irgendwer da, das ist schuld.
Aber wenn es so offensichtlich klar ist, dass man es selbst verkackt hat,
dann fällt es den Leuten, und ich kann's ja auch verstehen,
unglaublich schwer, sich das einzugestehen.
Und jetzt an der Stelle würden bestimmt 90 Prozent der Leute sagen,
ach, ist doch nicht so schlimm.
Jetzt hab ich endlich das, was ich haben will.
Jetzt mach ich ein bisschen weiter, spiel ich das Game noch weiter.
Ich hab so viel Geld reingesteckt schon.
Und, ähm, die blenden das komplett aus, dass sie 1.700 Euro verbrannt haben.
I have had a tough time sleeping.
And I think that this system is very predatory.
Okay, dass er jetzt anfängt zu weinen im Video,
ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel des Guten, aber, ja.
I think that this system is gambling.
Kleiner Bonus. Hier erlebt man die ...
Muss mittlerweile jedes Video, wo irgendwas, ähm, emotional ist,
überzeugt ist,
dass die Leute dann anfangen zu weinen auf YouTube.
Absolute Verzweiflung des Streamers Lakari.
Ja, gut, der Typ ist eh durch.
Von dem hab ich schon ein paar Highlights gesehen.
Der ist echt durch.
Als rund 1.700 Euro ausgegeben hat,
um einen Charakter in dem Spiel freizuschalten.
Oh, no, no, no, no!
Oh, my God!
Alter!
Als es endlich klappt, wandelt sich seine Panik in völlige Ekstase.
Der ist voll durch.
Okay.
Die aller-meisten Menschen betrifft das alles nicht.
Mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit hast du noch keine paar Tausend Euro
in ein Spiel gepumpt.
Für dich, mich und viele andere sind Spiele mit Lootboxen
und anderen Mikrotransaktionen einfach nur nervig.
Die meisten Spieler hätten lieber keine Ingame-Verkäufe.
Ja.
So ist es halt.
Doch darauf zielen diese Geschäftsmodelle auch gar nicht ab.
Nein, die Entwickler jagen Wale.
Gerade im Mobile-Gaming-Bereich
macht ein verschwindend geringer Teil der Spieler
den Großteil des Umsatzes ab.
Ja, tut das ja nichts Neues jetzt.
Ganz genaue Zahlen gibt es nicht.
Aber meist sind das irgendwo zwischen 0,1 und 2% der Spieler.
Da gab es ja mal so einen witzigen Bericht drüber von irgendeinem...
Keine Ahnung, irgendeinem Mobile-Game.
Und die sind ja dann so weit gegangen,
also die sind ja wirklich big brain, dass...
Ich glaube, das war...
Vielleicht war sogar ein Artikel in der GameStar.
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Zumindest hat da irgendein Entwickler drüber berichtet.
Nee, das war auf Englisch, das kann doch in der GameStar gewesen sein.
Aber egal.
Die haben da drüber berichtet, wie sie das gemacht haben.
Sie haben festgestellt, dass die halt ein paar Leute haben,
die besonders gut bezahlen.
Und daraufhin sind die, jetzt pass mal auf,
daraufhin haben die die Leute analysiert,
was die, ähm, was die gerne haben.
Das ging dann so weit, dass man auf die Facebook-Seiten der Leute ist
und sich geguckt hat, was mögen die.
Und dann haben die festgestellt, ah, der Typ kauft alles in Orange,
weil sein Lieblingsfußballverein
ein quasi orangenes Trikot hat, so nach dem Motto.
Also quasi Orange ist so sein Lieblings...
Die sind dann auf Facebook...
So, und daraufhin haben die explizit Items in das Game eingebaut,
die quasi orange waren und irgendwie angelehnt waren
an den Lieblingsfußballclub von diesem Typ.
Ohne dass sie Lizenzgebühren dafür bezahlen mussten oder so.
Also so gezielt wurde das da gemacht, ja?
Tausende, teils Zehntausende Euro in ein Spiel pumpen.
Es gibt lange Analysen und AI-Tools, wie man sein Spiel optimieren muss,
um diese Wale zu fangen und gezielt dazu zu bringen,
immer mehr Geld auszugeben.
Der Vortrag aus Kapitel 1 heißt zum Beispiel tatsächlich
Let's go whaling.
Es geht nicht darum...
Alter, was ist mit der Musik im Hintergrund los jetzt?
Übertreibst du? Da macht er immer wahnsinnig Drama draus.
...4.000 Euro anzubieten.
Spiele sollten so gestaltet werden, dass man jeden Tag aufs Neue
eine kleine bis mittlere Summe Geld ausgeben kann.
They are the guys who have all of the Clash of Clans building at the max level.
They are already there.
So you can no longer sell progress to them, you have to sell consumables.
This is where you are selling the faster healing times
or faster build times of armies.
This is also where you get basically unlimited upper spend.
Unlimited upper spend. Geil.
Das Narrativ in der Industrie ist häufig,
diese Leute hätten das Geld ja übrig.
Das sieht die Wissenschaft ganz anders.
Spieler, die zum Beispiel viele Lootboxen kaufen, sind nicht reich.
Es gibt Anzeichen, dass diese Menschen teils schlicht und einfach...
Wisst ihr, was eines der traurigsten Sachen war,
die ich so in diesem Zusammenhang...
Hatte es nicht direkt mit Mobile Games zu tun, die ich gelesen habe.
Dass einer der Top-Donator von, ich glaube, Ninja,
als er noch auf Twitch war, könnte auch DrDisRespect gewesen sein,
aber ich glaube, es war Ninja.
...dann...
Der eine der Top-Donator, das war ein ganz armer Sack im Endeffekt,
der Aufmerksamkeit quasi dadurch generieren wollte,
stimmt, er ist wieder auf Twitch,
dass er eben als der große Gönner in Twitch-Streams ist.
Der hat auch in anderen Sachen donatet,
hat auch bei The Friend donatet und sonst wie.
Den kannte man vom Namen her.
Der hat...
So, und am Ende kam raus,
...der Typ hatte nichts mehr.
Nicht sonderlich viel Geld.
Der hatte wohl irgendeine Auszahlung bekommen oder so.
Und was weiß ich, von irgendeiner Versicherung oder so was.
Müssen wir mal genauer nachgucken, ich krieg's nicht mal genau zusammen.
Zumindest der Punkt, worauf ich raus will,
der Kerl hat sich quasi in so einem Rausch donatet auf Twitch.
Und am Ende kam das Ganze nur raus, dass das gar kein Ölscheich ist oder so.
Weil der hat sich auch immer so als superreicher Gönner hingestellt.
Also, er fand das cool, dass Twitch ihn quasi so als...
Also sich als Ölscheich ansieht.
Und am Ende kam die ganze Sache bloß raus,
weil seine Frau auf Facebook geschrieben hat,
der Typ ist im Krankenhaus und ist schwer krank
und kann die Krankenhausrechnung nicht bezahlen.
Weil das Geld, was er hatte, hat er alles verdonatet.
Und die Versicherung, oder nee, oder was weiß ich, Versicherung und...
Also sprich, das, wo er jetzt eigentlich das bezahlen könnte,
hat er auch nicht mehr, weil er so viel donatet hat.
Das ist eigentlich schon krass, oder?
Das war echt eine der bittersten Geschichten,
die ich in dieser Richtung je gelesen habe.
Aber es ist relativ ähnlich, ja?
Der hat halt in irgendeiner Art und Weise Glücksgefühle, Bestätigungen,
was weiß ich, dadurch bekommen, dass er sich auf Twitter sehen,
als der krasse Ölscheich hinstellen konnte oder was auch immer er da war,
ja, und gehuldigt wurde von den Leuten.
Und das fand der halt nice.
Und das hat ihn so weit motiviert, dass er alles quasi dafür ausgegeben hat.
Was man weiß, ist, dass die Spieler, die nicht in der Welt der Spieler sind,
Menschen mit einer Glücksspielsucht,
die unkontrolliert immer mehr Geld ausgeben,
obwohl sie es häufig eigentlich nicht übrig haben.
Aber ganz genau weiß man das nicht.
Einfach weil Spieleentwickler ihre Daten
so gut wie nie mit Forschern wie Dr. Sendel teilen.
Vielleicht aus Angst, was er und andere
über die wahre Natur der Wale herausfinden.
Hey, einfach weil es Geld bringt.
Was die rausfinden, ist denen wahrscheinlich relativ egal.
Die Daten sind pures Money für die.
Natürlich sind nicht alle Spiele so aufgebaut.
Und nicht jeder Entwickler ist derart auf Profite um jeden Preis aus.
Viele Next-Gen-Games sind in jeder Hinsicht absolute Meisterwerke.
Dazu kommen zahllose tolle Indie-Spiele.
Etliche Free-to-Play-Titel sind toll umgesetzt
und finanzieren sich sehr erfolgreich auf faire Art und Weise.
Doch die Videospielindustrie wächst immer, immer weiter.
Sie ist heute schon größer als die Musik- und Filmindustrie ...
Das wissen viele gar nicht.
Gerade die bisschen älteren Semester,
klar, die haben auch gemerkt, dass Gaming mittlerweile
viel mehr in der Gesellschaft angekommen ist,
aber das ist denen gar nicht klar.
Und Mikrotransaktionen machen einen immer größeren Anteil ...
Gut, Blizzard schrumpft, da ist aber Blizzard selbst dran schuld.
Letztes Jahr war es schon über 20 Prozent.
Noch deutlicher macht es der Umsatz
des Industriegiganten Activision Blizzard.
Innerhalb von nur sieben Jahren sind Microtransactions und Abos
das Hauptgeschäft des Unternehmens geworden.
Bei vielen Entwicklern ist die Verlockung vermutlich groß,
die Spiele richtig heftig durchzumonetarisieren.
Denn es funktioniert ganz offensichtlich.
Genshin Impact ist ein unglaublicher finanzieller Erfolg.
Es hat diese Art von Free-to-Play-Lootbox-Spiel
auf die Konsole gebracht.
Andere werden versuchen, das zu reproduzieren.
Das war auch der Grund, warum ich das nie gespielt hab.
Ich hab das System dahinter erfahren, hab ich mir gedacht, nö, kein Bock.
Obwohl das Spiel an sich eigentlich gar nicht schlecht ist.
Als ich das gehört hab, was das Monetarisierungssystem dahinter ist,
hab ich gesagt, nö, spiel ich nicht. Warum soll ich das machen?
... ist finanziell so wichtig für EA,
dass der Konzern es sich überhaupt nicht erlauben kann,
den Modus grundlegend zu verändern.
Das steht tatsächlich in etwas anderen Worten
im letzten Jahresbericht des Entwicklers.
Sind diese Geschäftsmodelle wirklich nachhaltig?
Spiele, die sich über die Ausbeutung einiger weniger Menschen finanzieren?
Man könnte sich zumindest in diesem Extremfall selbst regulieren.
Zum Beispiel mit Limits, wie viel ein Spieler in einem Game ausgibt.
Warum sollten die sich selbst regulieren?
Das ist aber nicht Stonks.
... people with gambling problems, they're very vulnerable.
Das ist denen doch scheißegal.
Aus moralischer Sicht hat er natürlich vollkommen recht.
Aber das ist den Stonks-Leuten doch vollkommen egal.
Die würden auch ihre Mutter ausbeuten, das ist denen doch wurscht.
Und das ist das Problem mit den Lootboxen.
Just cut off that top 1% of spending.
Just say nobody's spending more than $100 a month on these.
Abseits davon muss man bei Lootboxen über Altersbeschränkungen reden.
Immer und überall klar angezeigte Gewinnchancen
und Preise in Echtgeld.
Am Ende geht es um die Frage, was ...
Klar angezeigte Gewinnchancen, das ist schon das Erste,
wo man tricksen kann.
Dann schreibst du hin, 80% Gewinnchancen,
und da guckst du, was du zu 80% bekommst.
Mit einem Gold. Mit einem Gold kannst du nichts anfangen.
Niemand scrollt dann runter ...
eine Liste mit 300 Wahrscheinlichkeiten,
was du bekommen kannst und so was.
Games sein wollen.
Vehikel für fragwürdige Praktiken, um Geld zu verdienen.
Fun-Story.
Fangnetze für anfällige Personen, die man dann ganz eklig Wale tauft.
Oder Produkte, Kunstwerke, die wirklich geldwert sind.
Es ist nicht so, dass sich alles in Richtung Lootboxen bewegt.
Es gibt auch recht viele und sind auch leider sehr populäre Spiele.
Es gibt durchaus noch gute Games.
Im Grunde kannst du dich ja wirklich überall austoben.
Du kannst überall Sachen finden und bist gar nicht eingeschränkt.
Ist ja nicht so, als wäre der Korridor nur aus Lootbox-Games.
Es gibt aber halt, ja ...
Ja.
Es gibt halt einfach viele.
Und das sind eben die, die auch in your face überall dastehen.
Wer macht Werbung? Shadow Legends, nicht irgendwelche ...
What the fuck?
Ich will nix über Funk wissen.
Wow, okay, Alter. So.
Äh, kurz Musik anmachen.
Das ist wie AGBs, die liest man. Ja, so ungefähr.
Raid Shadow Legends.
Also, man muss ja sagen, Geld haben die genug, ne?
Die waren ja bei mir auch schon am Start.
Und ich weiß es nicht mehr. Ich hab's irgendwann mal im Stream erzählt.
Ich glaub, 1.500 Euro oder irgendwas.
Einfach so für meinen Popel-Stream, ja?
Für irgendwie eine Stunde zeigen oder so.
Also, das war schon echt nicht ohne.
Und dann irgendwie noch an Beteiligung,
und so was.
Also, die schmeißen Geld raus wie nix.
Aber mit denen werd ich nix machen.
So, ähm ...
Was kommen wir uns jetzt als Nächstes an? Zeig mal her.
Ich habe meinen 1000 ...
12.090 K gekillt.
Oh, nee, nee, kein New World Flame.
New World ... Also, wir müssen uns, glaub ich,
heute kein New World Flame-Video angucken, weil ...
Weil, Sekunde ...
Die New World Steam Stats sprechen für sich.
Innerhalb der ersten paar Wochen, Alter.
Tja, ich hab's euch gesagt, Leute. Februar gucken wir mal.
Mal gucken, ob ich recht hab.
Es sieht aber alles so aus, wenn das ...
Es sieht sogar so aus, als geht es noch schneller als ich das ...
mir ursprünglich mal gedacht hab.
Die sind runter von ungefähr 900.000 auf Dings.
Also, sie haben die Hälfte der Spieler,
um's jetzt mal schön zu rechnen, sogar noch mehr.
Also, sie haben quasi 55 Prozent der Spieler verloren
in den ersten paar Wochen. Das ist schon krass.
Vor allem hat das halt noch ...
so einen hohen Anspruch.
Hast du schon von den Bugs mit der Schadensberechnung gelesen?
Ja. Klar, da gibt's nicht nur Bugs mit der Schadensberechnung.
Von Gold-Duplication-Bugs bis, ähm ...
Äh, äh, Unlimited-Sprint und so alles, alles kannst du vergessen.
Also, New World ist so extremst broken,
dass wir ihn auch nicht mehr auf die Reihe kriegen.
Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
PC am Straßenrand gewohnt, das ist doch bestimmt fake, oder?
Das ist doch bestimmt fake.
Fake.
Ich meine, eigentlich ist das eine richtig big-brain Idee.
Also, gehen wir jetzt ...
Ich will ihm nicht unterstellen, dass es fake ist, oder?
Also, wahrscheinlich ist es legit.
Aber nur mal von der Theorie her.
Eigentlich wäre das eine big-brain Idee, ähm ...
So könnte man easy Videos generieren.
Du nimmst dir einfach einen alten Rechner irgendwo her,
sagst, keine Ahnung, äh ...
Du hast den Straßenrand gefunden, ob das stimmt oder nicht.
Wer will das nachvollziehen?
Das kennen wir schon.
Okay.
Dann, weiß ich nicht.
Äh, Amazon, Philips Hue, zehn Jahre ...
Haben wir das Battle ...
Haben wir die Battlefield-Topplays geguckt hier schon
vor letztem, letztem Mal?
Ich glaube nicht, oder?
Extrem dreckiger Raucher-PC.
Äh, was hab ich denn da alle drauf gemacht?
Okay, ich will mir das Video nicht angucken.
Ich will mal bloß gucken, was extrem dreckig bedeutet.
Mh!
Gelb halt.
Uäh!
Okay, wie sieht das Ding von innen aus?
Tomtrix, danke für den Sub.
Ja, es ist halt gelber Staub, aber ansonsten ...
Ist halt ver-ver-ver- ...
Wie gehts, Alter?
Wo hat das Mainboard, Alter?
Ah, nee, hör mal auf.
Cu, weg damit.
so haben wir das battlefield topless schon geguckt sekunde chat das ist was
hat mir letztens eine fritzburg 7500 im wald fahrradwege von ach ja ziemlich
demoliert aber auch um sich in die läuft wunderbar und bin dann dreimal lang
gelaufen um restliche gehäuse teilen zu finden
chat chat ist der umwelt zuliebe wieder unterwegs ja das haben wir schon gesehen
aber das schon gesehen wirklich ah ja das haben wir schon gesehen das haben
wir schon gesehen naja das kommt mir bekannt vor ja das
haben wir schon gesehen das haben wir schon gesehen ok gibt es irgendwas neues
nein gibt nichts neues ja gut so langweilig soll youtube ich brauche
irgendwas noch hummer gedächtnis ja ich kann mir das nicht alles merken
okay da gucken wir uns das video von bauer an mit der dicken katz davor
jawohl
Wobei, ich glaube, das ist gar nicht
Sonderlich spannend
Ich mein
Wahrscheinlich hat er seine CPU irgendwie
Zu krass übertaktet
Und das ist nicht so super spannend
Äh, ja, was gucken wir denn jetzt
Mir fällt jetzt
Tja, er hat eine Schraube
Drauf geschmissen, F
Also, Firearms
Experts React
Möchte mir das YouTube wirklich
Aufs Auge drücken, ne
Was, das Amazon ist echt gut
Wie lang ist das, Zack?
Du meinst das hier, was der Chat gerade gepostet hat
1 Stunde 53
Nein, das gucken wir jetzt ganz bestimmt nicht
Wir können Inside Amazons
Massive Data Center gucken
Gucken, was da rauskommt
Tinder
Ja
Ja, jetzt übertreibts mal nicht
Moment, Moment, ich will immer
Ich gucke immer gern, was die auf den Displays haben
Moment, Moment, ich will immer gern was die auf den Displays haben
Ah, man sieht nix
Man sieht nix
Das ist leider zu unscharf
Ich frage mich immer, ob das fake ist
Gibt es wirklich Leute, die ohne Maus arbeiten
Im Büro
Das ist doch alles fake, oder?
Niemand arbeitet ohne Maus
Vor allem nicht mit zwei Monitoren
Und wenn man viel im Browser unterwegs ist
Das ist doch alles fake, oder?
Dann ist das einfach so
Und wenn man viel im Browser unterwegs ist
Aber Bezos ist fast-growing Retailer
Was having difficulties setting up
And rolling out its own internal server
Boah, die Hacker-Mens sind am Start, ja
Und was swiftly identified
By the more enterprising young guns in the room at least
As a potential spin-off service
Amazon could sell on to other companies
Fast forward to today
And AWS rakes in a whopping 60%
Of all Amazon profits
That's about 50 billion dollars
That's about 50 billion dollars a year
How?
By taking on other companies' tech problems
In the cloud
If you're a startup
Okay, das ist Video für Ultra-Noobs, oder?
In 2021, you no longer need
Ich mein, inside massive data center
Aktuell seh ich da irgendwelche Stock
Stocks
Video
Stock-Video-Footage
To invest precious capital gearing
In this region
Cameras
Staff
Any reason
As such
Das ist ja Paintschamp
The so-called 100-Point-Checklist
Supervised by external bodies
Hyper-Systems
Security-Servers
And software operations
Are translated
Data centers
Essential to provide security
Okay, das ist sinnlos
Backup for crucial client info
Das ist sinnlos
Richtig sinnlos
Matchy baited als bei Levelcap
Ja, echt so
Hallo, YouTube, please
Startseil
Jetzt ist auch noch YouTube gecrashed
Leute, mein Tab ist gecrashed
So Resident Sleeper war das Video
Gibt's nicht irgendwas Gescheites
Was wir noch gucken können?
Mensch, YouTube
Irgendwas Kurzes, vielleicht
Angespannte Corona-Lage in Russland
Ist mir vollkommen egal
Why did Facebook go down?
Ja, das haben wir uns ja sogar zusammen
Im Stream schon angeschaut
Also nicht das Video
Sondern was das Problem war
Döner-Tour Lübeck
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wo Lübeck ist
Irgendwo an der Nordsee, oder?
Keine Ahnung, wo ist Lübeck?
Ostsee?
Na, war ich doch schon mal gar nicht verkehrt
Na, die Richtung stimmte
Ich glaube nicht, dass Wayland
Irgendwie was Gescheites noch wird
X ist aber auch Müll
Zuschauer-PC vom Blitz getroffen
Jetzt übertreiben sie
Was macht jetzt PewDiePie hier auf?
Auf MrBeast?
Irgendwelche Challenges
Meine Güte, gibt's irgendwelche gescheiten Videos zur Abwechslung nochmal?
Der Tesla-Bot ist ein schlechter Witz
What the fuck?
Also da klickt man doch auch noch wegen dem Subnail drauf, oder?
Das haben wir schon geguckt
Oh, was ist das?
Oh man
Es gibt nix zu gucken, Leute
Das ist ja schlimm
New Beautiful Smart Home Gadgets
Ja, da ist wahrscheinlich wer...
Das ist doch der Typ, der in jedem zweiten Satz sagt Alexa, oder?
Was ist denn mit YouTube grad los?
Warum ist denn das so broken?
Was ist denn hier?
Der Browser ist komplett, komplett
Gegenteil von Vogue
Der ist kaputt
Ja, der Browser ist im Arsch
Was ist das hier?
Meine Güte
Ja
Geht dann irgendwas?
Was anderes auf?
Ne, mein Browser ist kaputt
Okay, null
Was ist, wenn ich sage, hier, New Window?
Was du?
Warum ist mein Chrome im Arsch?
Okay, ich glaube, es wird Zeit, einfach mal alles auszumachen
Ah, jetzt geht's wieder
Okay, X, X, X
Oh, jetzt die Musik ist ein wenig laut
Okay, alles
So
Tja, Leute, es gibt nix zu gucken
Es ist nur Müll
Nur
Wir können auch die anderen drei Videos gucken
Aber ehrlich gesagt
Gehen alle so lang
Du musst mehr RAM down-downen
Leute, ich weiß, was ich mache
Ich muss noch ein Battlefield-Video aufnehmen
Habe ich mir jetzt ein paar Tage vorgedrückt
Dadurch, dass wir heute schon
Für früh online waren
Kann ich jetzt noch ein Battlefield-Video für heute mit darauf nehmen
So mache ich das
Ich gehe jetzt auf
Und nehme Battlefield-Video auf
Und ich nehme schon die ganze Zeit machen
Und lade ich das nachher rauf
Ich habe jetzt schon wieder eine Woche oder so
Nichts hochgeladen
Mit echt Zeit
Ja
Können jetzt weiter pennen, Leute
Wir sehen uns
Bis dann, CU